it's
all right we again call the meeting to
order I'm going to be chairing today for
the morning um Senator abis is in court
uh he will he'll be here for one so I'll
take it till 12:45 is then I got to go
run off and catch a bus to catch a plane
um and Senator Whitley or Senator Ganon
will take over for the last 15 20
minutes in the morning and then um we'll
take a break for lunch come back at one
o'clock sen Abby should be here and
we'll continue on so just to give you a
rough idea our goal is again we're just
going to continue we have the state
treasurer here today to to testify and
answer questions around cannabis and and
and the finances of it um but until then
we have the minutes from the last
meeting in front of you and I would
entertain a motion to adopt the
minutes somebody anybody make a motion
to adopt the minutes from last meeting
it's been moved by representative Kill
seconded by Senator Gana to adopt the
minutes of
11923 are there any edits that anybody
would like um just that I was uh marked
as present and absent so I was here last
week that's the only
edit you were here last there move you
up there great so with that adjustment
is there any other adjustments to the
minutes seeing none all those in favor
say I I all oppose nay the eyes have it
the minutes are
adopted next up uh Monica M Miss Pell if
you want to come on up and um I think
there was some people had some questions
for you and I don't know if you want to
give any testimony relative to the bill
it yeah I apologize s of the gon would
you lead us in the pledge
sure I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
Justice thank you representative k for
reminding
past just remember to hit your
microphone and give your name and that
minutes good morning Mr chair and
members of the commission uh for the
record State Treasurer Monica mapelli
and with me this morning is um Chief
Deputy Treasurer Rachel Miller just
joining me um so uh thank you very much
for for inviting us to to come over
today um I do have a few points that I
think I would like to cut cover first
but then um sounds more than anything um
I'll be happy to answer any questions
the commission may have for for
us and I know there's some hands outs um
being
um
distributed
so it's the one pager that Miss Mell is
referencing well thank you very much it
sounds like everyone has the hand out um
so there's probably really not a lot new
uh in this page but um essentially from
um my understanding of what the model uh
there isbi um um right now is being um
explored uh by this commission is to
establish uh a franchise model where the
uh uh Liquor Commission is going to
oversee uh the franchises uh the
franchises and and and The Business of
legalizing cannabis in the state so um
some of the points that I'm just
including here is really had to do have
to do with banking um but perhaps
because uh the banking Association is is
is here as you probably all very
familiar with some of the concerns um
that exist around um banking but um so
my first point um the first ball is
really um the banking may represent um a
challenge for for the potential retail
owners um uh my understanding is there
are some um out ofate uh chhada Banks
and perhaps in State chhat Bank banks
that are will be willing to to do
business uh with some of the retail
owners um but again uh there will be
those challenges and and until
legislation is passed at the federal
level really those those challenges are
not going to go away um nothing really
has changed over the years in in that
you know in that um related to that
aspect so so again that represents a
rest for for um again the banking
represents a rest for for some thanks
and again
for uh for the potential owners of uh of
cannabis business so so uh for example
my understanding is the existing
facilities selling cannabis for medical
purposes um I don't know this for a fact
but I believe they're doing banking with
uh banks in Massachusetts so um again
that may be different right now but
minus that's how they begin um their
establishments so the second point is
really that the state may face some some
similar challenges we we are aware that
um we are fully aware that there are
some banks that don't want to be
associated with with the Cannabis uh
again due to the regulations at the
feral level um so we know there are
some we know of banks that have again
different different positions so may be
willing to um want to continue doing
business with the state and and and
treat our Revenue the same way uh but
there are some banks that clear CLE have
said no we we don't want to be
associated with that so some of our
challenges are going to be um so the
third Point again I'm just sort of
rolling now um the third point is we do
have uh many relationships Bank banking
relationships with many banks um but we
conduct most of our business with the
three major um federally chared Banks
and the state um we do that because of
the large footprint in in their
infrastructure they have accommodate the
the state's business what the state
needs to conduct this business um so so
with with those relationships we have to
really uh consider and and have clear
discussions um about whether they're
willing to continue um uh you know just
considering um the collections the
revenue collections if they're okay
considering those just like any
collections or or they don't want to
have anything to do with that because
they know there is cannabis um revenue
and um
commingle with that so again we've seen
we've heard two positions um and so it
would be a matter of reviewing our
agreements with them having conversation
with them at them and perhaps re
receiving some guidance from the um
Attorney General's office as to how we
should proceed in those cases if the
legislation were to
pass um so that's um related to U again
our our potential challenges that we we
may see um um U again if this leg leg
istion were to pass um and I sort of um
just went down to to the last Point um
you know from a cash um FL perspective
and again this is based on a little bit
of what we have learned we've learned uh
how the commission is planning to to uh
do the collections of of you know the
franchise fee um we which just want to
mention that you know at the treasury we
care about our cash flows so um if this
um businesses are going to be charged um
um a franchise fee based on gr sales um
and those are monthly sales the state
could benefit for that monthly
collection of Revenue um it's that's
what most states do they tax and they
collect those revenues on a monthly
basis so having that uh Revenue stream
uh predictable Revenue stream for the
state will be beneficial for again to to
maintain
um um just comfortable cash level
especially now in the amount of the the
the um the estimates that we're
hearing the potentially large amount of
Revenue will will come back to the state
from these fees um so that's sort of
what I wanted to cover again not really
knowing what the commission wanted to
really hear from us but those are the
points that um again thinking about the
potential challenges nothing new all the
states have facing similar challenges um
you know again we will probably have
more conversations for um neighboring
states Maine um Vermont to see how
they're handling some of those you know
again potential challenges um and again
I'm perhaps receiving guidance from the
um um the bank and Department that might
help uh also try to make things simple
once those um you know once all these uh
business owners are able to establish
banking
relationships um then the state probably
should have again the state you have um
you know less challenges we want to
collect um we here as a cash business
that's that's always risky to have you
know large amounts of cash um so
preferably the St will collect money you
know electronically via check um
hopefully we don't see cash coming to us
as a form of Revenue
so again this is all I have for remarks
I'll be happy to answer any questions
great so I I just want to start with
just some some some of what I think I
know and maybe you can confirm um it so
we can understand the banking and what
might happen around this is my
understanding is the US Treasury
Financial crimes enforcement Network Von
has has issued guidance for banks to be
able to how they deal with cannabis so
banks are allowed to but there are some
that may still want to stay away for
whatever business reasons but that's my
understanding there is there are a set
of guidelines for banks to
follow is it you is that
correct
all we are hearing again this there's
more that we need to again evaluate all
our existing relationships but um we're
clear some some banks that we do
business with currently they have a very
clear position that they will not get
involved um they don't even want to know
about Revenue coming from the Cannabis
industry so so that's one clear position
and we just need to understand those
positions um and and and figured out how
to to cond again collect our Revenue
based on those banks that are willing to
to uh to accept this um so as this so so
again if this bill was to move forward
and common law the
banking concerns for the state is we do
we are already doing businesses that
would be willing to accept these kind of
funds um understanding the finson
requirements and managing it that way is
that is that true I believe so I think
part of the reason we we never really
had a very uh in-depth discussion with
the banks is because for us it was um no
no one really uh brought this up as a
problem so for us it's been uh again the
licensing the the license fees that
we've been collecting those have been
coming as regular Revenue it's really
more now that we're asking the questions
you know were more um you know more
direct with banks you know do you have
any suggestions and then we again from
one of our existing Partners was very
clear their position we wouldn't we
wouldn't accept this Revenue but but
again we do business with uh many banks
and and and I know for sure they will
have different positions great and the
last question I have is or understanding
I have is again this bill establishes a
new fund under the state for the purpos
of you know um treatment programs and
and other things that's not going to be
a problem to manages as well creating a
fund like that within the state you
think that's able I think the concern is
the co-mingling of money right where and
if if the feds ever decide to swoop in
and do something that we have that money
as a separate you know not comingled
with other state money so they don't
just confiscate the entire bank account
so to speak yeah that's going to be very
difficult especially so so so creating a
fund is not a problem um that that's
that's very simple um the accounting as
you know once
this it'll be interesting how we how we
handle this but the fund yes I mean the
accounting of that fund will be clear
and but there's money coming and going
to several places it'll be transfers to
Department of Health and Human Services
transfers to the to education trust fund
so um it's going to be complicated in
terms of keeping that clean I mean there
are things that we can do again we you
know you know for examp um yeah great
question I think um you know one of the
things that we can do you know in terms
of cash we could probably have again try
to segregate the funds themselves and
notom mangle them with the regular State
business um that's something we will
explore um the fund itself the
accounting will have specific tracking
of all of the transactions so I think
there'll be a way to to Really
differentiate if the federal government
came after the state to to say okay this
is this relates to the Canabis um
business collections great questions
committee thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question it seems to
me um when we're talking about banking
relationships under bullet number two um
it would be a smart decision not to uh
engage in this um scheme it it seems to
me um it it constitutes money laundering
doesn't
it it it
does um it we would just be operating
under state law um again I think um at
the feral level there are discussions
about uh for example The Proposal of the
um uh the safe banking act that sounds
like his um has by pison support um it's
just you know once and every state is
dealing with that there are so many
states doing business so I think it's
just a matter of time
um but but you're absolutely correct
it's it's just not legal at the federal
level um you mentioned uh the banks that
the state is currently dealing with many
are uh you know refusing
uh to do business with an illegal
operation uh so how um has have any
stepped forward that said yes I'm all
in we are aware of one one bank at least
again we haven't had open conversations
with with the banks again just because
um I was trying to prepare for for you
know for this meeting um but but
certainly we'll have we have to have
those conversations with all the banks
and review our agreements there's one
particular band we had to opportunity to
speak with uh recently and their view is
that the there's
a the business that the state will
conduct is is not directly related to
the Cannabis meaning there is not the
liquid stores selling the product is
really um the stores selling it and then
they're just remitting that um the fees
the taxes however this is going to be
called um so that's they see it as a
separate it um meaning having an
indirect relationship or receiving that
indirectly allows them to collect uh
those revenues in and transact with us
that's this particular bank's view uh
again not all have the same view one
followup please one more that that being
the case um would that limit liability
to the state with that 15% Revenue uh it
seems to me that that's still under
finsen would be
um
illegal I I'm not um probably not the
right person to speak about liability I
think uh probably you know all of those
discussions will have to be um held with
Department of Justice and we will have
those discussions again once because we
will have to review our existing um
existing agreements as far as we know
there are some Clauses that speak about
um um is it that we don't do any illegal
business this section internet gambling
like internet gambling and then we we
clarify that is
is we're not going to do state is not
engaged in illegal business so some of
those some some of that language will
have to probably be reviewed and again
we're not the right uh group to speak
about the liability but that's what
we'll have to do work with the Attorney
General's office on that thank you so I
just want to make sure but at least one
Bank the state's already doing business
with follows the finson guidelines and
would be willing to do business under
the federal guidelines for working with
cannabis that's my understand it right
now Ryan I think you had a question yeah
not so much question but just to kind of
help uh with the conversation so um
you're correct uh uh Treasurer um
there's different tiers of of marijuana
related businesses tier one is directly
touching the product right so a little
bit higher risk there's tier two and
then tier three um you know I think what
was proposed in 1598 where the state
would be selling directly that created
tier one marijuana level and so the risk
was higher um this is fees and um and
taxes um so lower level but again banks
have different risk thresholds risk
tolerances um you know we are aware of a
number of banks that are interested in
getting into it um and one of the things
that during 1598 debate we did ask for
was to make sure that those funds were
separate and distinct from all other
funds and that was to ensure that
current banking
relationship uh that the state has Isn't
interrupted in the event that that um
that bank didn't want to take uh those
funds and then another bank could Step
Up um but again we are aware of a number
of banks that are um interested in
getting into into uh marijuana
banking marijuana related businesses um
and again this is a lower tier um that
we're discussing in this bill so great
thank you any other questions from the
chairman just one one statement that the
treasurer made that we're fine with a
monthly reimbursement instead of a
quarterly reimbursement The Liquor
Commission is fine with that the model
was just to to collect those franchise
fees and make it a little bit easier on
the franchisee to do it a quarterly but
monthly would be fine as
well thank
you yeah I can also just on the safe
Banking Act just to give an update on
that um it's passed the house seven
times it's always failed in the Senate
our senate committee um a month or so
ago uh marked up and passed it I think
it was 149 so it's it is making some
Headway
um you know it has the support in the
house the question and they Advocates
feel that they do have the votes in the
Cent they have 60 votes in the Senate to
get it through so um obviously a lot has
changed there's a lot going on right now
down in Congress keeping the government
open but uh we do they we have been told
that that is one of their priorities so
um if that is if that does pass that
will make it take uh a lot of these
questions off the table and make it
easier so great
anything
else thank you madam treasure for coming
appreciate it very much thank you very
much all right so we're going to
continue on in the bill um we last left
off on page at the top of page 15 letter
F and I'm just going to kind of remind
people what that section is talking
about um so we go back to page 13 number
four um we're talking about rulemaking
at this point right uh not later than we
decided on 30 months after the effective
date of the section the commission shall
initiate Ru making process to 90 uh 541a
for regulations on Advertising
manufacturer sale of cannabis cannabis
products cannabis accessories and the
rulle shall include the following and we
made it all the way to F on page 15 so
again we're talking about the fact that
liquor uh needs to adopt rules and this
is relative to packaging product
manufacturing labeling requirements for
cannabis and cannabis products included
but not limited to and we have a list of
things talking about how package
um uh would look what would look like
so Chief I'm not sure U Mr M sorry I
didn't mean I meant the the liquor Chief
there
um given in light of your most recent
Adventures um do you have any comments
about anything we might add in here to
make sure it's clear and distinct for
packaging and and labeling that you know
what it can or cannot contain that we
might want to put specifically in the
bill
the only thing I would add Mr chairman
is we've done a lot of study with the
states that have legalized the 24 states
that have legalized cannabis at this
point and we would just continue to uh
look at what they're doing and model
what we're doing off after the what we
feel are the states that are doing it
the best which
are which are there's a few out there
that are doing it well okay so going
through uh Tim just kind of a question
for chairman Mica you know with with the
uh recent push back of the micro
breweries on packaging um for for their
micro brew containers um some containing
cartoons that look like you know Finding
Nemo do you think do you think you guys
are um going to be able to stop stuff
packaging I do this is the way I we look
at it we would we would ask that the
packaging uh much like beer Laing or
anything else that we inspect we would
we would set a criteria out that it
can't be that cannot happen in the state
and would ask manufacturers because I'm
sure there's manufacturers in other
states that are interested in coming to
ma uh coming to New Hampshire with their
products we would ask that those those
labels or packages uh meet our standards
rather than the standards of other
states so I certainly think that it's
something that we can do
representative I think if you look again
at the rules under F uh small I number D
and E right we talk about athletes right
not being depicted of so it's no way
informed being a performance-enhancing
product and the same with cartoon you
know characters not packaged for
featuring illustration subject matter
attributes that are consistent with
products marketed towards Children and
Youth right so they have some pretty
clear guidelines that they'll do and and
maybe even ad in rules a little tighter
guidelines as well so um I think Jordan
you have a yeah two quick comments
there's some grammatical errors in the
U uh list of the laundry list where at
oh for example um but not limited to the
following statements on the packaging
our fault that are
faults
Etc that type of U language
occurs um but a question to The Liquor
Commission go ahead
you've already been in discussion with
the 24 other states you already have
some idea what the rules are is it going
to take 30 months or can it be done in a
month or
two the 30 months representative doesn't
represent what the uh the packaging
would represent the 30 months represents
our business partners being able to come
to the state and set up growth
facilities and Manufacturing facilities
that's where that's where the the lead
time is is
necessary what follow up Mr jacket well
the my understanding is that you've
already got a line of people that are
ready to come in uh they need rules in
order to set up so besides them coming
in they're ready to come in but what
they need is a set of rules for
operation so by if it's going to take 30
months for them to set up and 30 months
to put in the ruled you're now talking
60 mon you're
talking a rather long period of
time it's my understanding in that 30
months representative that the rules
would would be uh would be written and
sent to jail car in conjunction with our
business partners coming to the state
and setting up their businesses so the
30 months is a is just that 30 months
and if it happens in 22 months or 18
months so be it but we just want to make
sure that we're not in a position where
we're asking people
to where we're asking franchisees to
open stores when we don't have enough
product for them to sell so chief of
Comm if I can so again you're talking
about a staggered set of rules coming in
it's a not 30 months is a not to exceed
number right you have to have everything
done within 30 months but I I would
assume that I'm serving on jail car and
I'm praying you don't show up with a a
stack of rules like this for all all
levels of the uh but you're going to do
like assume you'll do cultivation first
and then move into manufacturing and
then move into the distribution and then
move into retail so as the people who
have to stage and stagger will get ready
so when you get to the final product of
the franchise store there's already
product on the back end to deal with
that is that is that an accurate
assessment of a stagger can't say it
better than you said it yes yeah great
so uh separ he's good uh Mr chair I have
a question about the process um um I
know you've been collecting God rails
from um subject am experts that have
come in uh I submitted a god rails from
the prevention Community um I don't
think we need to go through each and
every one of those right now will o OLS
be integrating these into the the marked
up copy that we're doing today so I was
hoping to have a Redline product by
today that we could see all the changes
we've made up to this date but yes
ultimately we'll end up with a Redline
product with all the additions and
subtractions that we've done to the from
the draft bill from the that's after
after our yeah after we're all done okay
and remember the biggest in through all
of these rule making stuff you'll always
see the language as um Li you know not
not limited too right and the argument
is that we may not put it in the law but
the liquor can take the sheet that
you've submitted and integrate into that
rules anyway even though we didn't
specifically outline that right there's
there's 12 we have 12 suggestions um on
packaging and also uh several warnings
and I don't want to hold up the process
by going through each one of these right
now but we we we can integrate that into
the recommendation so the one thing I
I'll remind the committee is that there
are things we're not agreeing on right
uh I'm gon I'm going to go back to my
favorite topic right now is a public
consumption argument we're having right
now what happens on a first offense what
happens on a subsequent offense right I
think we all agree that subsequent
offense should have uh an enhanced
penalty over a first offense we just
can't get to what what it looks like
right and so what I anticipate is we'll
go back we'll modify that section to say
that that first offense that a
subsequent offense will have an enhanced
penalty but we're going to leave it to
the policy Committee in the house to
decide what that looks like because
we're not going to come to an agreement
right and we'll let the people in the
criminal justice committee make that
determination because they they'll do it
in align with all the other
determination they had on other things
like we're talking about public
consumption uh public smoking in general
and what the penalties are for that whe
they're corollary or not so I I don't
want to get bogged down too much in some
details because again the policy
committee is going to take this and tear
it all apart our goal is to set a bill
with the ideas of what we want and as
much detail as we can that we where we
can come to consensus and wherever we
don't we can have a majority and
Minority Report on that section so I
anticipate on the public consumption
component we're going to have a majority
and minority we're going to have a
standard statement that basically says
the bill we think again I think it
should be violation of misdemeanor I'm
not willing will to set penalties and
violation levels of I mean uh penalty
levels but I'm willing to set the
violation the levels and let the policy
committee decide the majority report's
going to say a second offense we think
is should be significantly enhanced
because you're knowingly violating the
law at that point you've already been
warned on a first offense there are some
people here that disagree with that
model and the minority can say we don't
think so we're decriminalizing marijuana
and we don't think that we should Rec
criminalize another action involving
marijuana that may be their statement
but we'll have two different policies
statements to where it is that the
policy committee can take up and Define
further does that make sense to
everybody great all right so section F
we've got uh Jordan's minor um
correction and we've got the um some of
the languaging that will give the licker
for better enhancement on the regulation
on on packaging is there any other
cover not see any moving
on we will go to we're now on page 16
number
five Mr chair just a recommendation on
five uh when it talks about a government
ID perhaps uh there should be some
consideration to using the same language
used in the DMB
statutes uh with respect to
identification there is no definition
earlier in this proposed legislation
with respect to what a government ID is
and so perhaps just using the current
language that's used for DMV would be
question I'll see if I can dig that up
and I'm okay with that if everyone else
is if we have consistent language
somewhere else in statute that talks
about uh in liquor for example we have
to have something that talks about what
is a valid government ID for the
purposes of identification and we can
cop copy and use that language so it's
consistent more for enforcement reasons
for liquor they're using the same
standard both for alcohol and marijuana
considering the same people are going to
be enforcing it makes sense to try to
normalize that as much as
possible
Jordan um we have uh RSA 264 to consider
as well regarding the scanning of the
driver's license to make sure that that
doesn't take
place right I I don't think there's
anywhere in the bill we're talking about
the scanning and and retention of
Licensing yeah I just want
anything else belt and suspenders
anything else on
five
six I think Jordan here's your no
data everybody okay with six it
basically says the only way they can
keep the data is if for marketing
allows number
seven Mr
chair yes we should probably change uh
24 to 30 like we did in the other
reasonable anything else Qui question I
know you been here go ahead um what if
there was a recall there was a product
feack something but in wouldn't be able
to the consumer if there was something
in the product good question Chief what
do you have for what if we have a a
batch that shows up bad we don't catch
it until the independent review later
after it's already been on the market
how do we how we deal with notification
to Consumers that a given batch might
have a
problem it's my understanding that
nothing would make it to the Shelf until
the the the process of inspecting it
took place but then if if in in fact
something was out there that had a
problem in it we would would basically
be through through the Liquor Commission
that that that type of information would
come out uh through our social media
through our website and through uh
so so one second see what the next
number
is so maybe Chief this is talking about
rules so maybe under we can add a number
nine that just talks about uh
notification of recall possible
processes and just add add that you you
have to require some sort of rules for
notification does that seem reasonable
to
everybody so we'll add a number
nine and it'll just be your recall
notification yes um currently if there's
a batch of um I'll just used one that
popped into my mind Blue Bunny Ice Cream
they had a leria problem uh three or
four years ago and all they did was
public record as the uh commissioner
just commented so I I think it's pretty
I'm sure they have a process and I'm
sure they can add something simply in
again I think of you know just simple
what's signage at the signage at the
stores that kind of thing the franchise
locations as well as social media posts
for by both required probably be enough
notice but there should be a process in
place so we'll just add that they'll
adopt rules relative to
that so we're changing it to 30 we're
adding in number eight about recalls
everybody else okay with uh number seven
Mr chair Mr chair excuse me good okay uh
number seven uh from a public health and
uh perspective we would uh recommend or
consider for the commission to add or to
ensure that there's
information uh in the handout that uh
must
contain uh informative uh material
regarding the health hazards associated
with cannabis products including but not
limited to restrictions uh on use by
persons who are pregnant breastfeeding
as well as health hazards associated
with chronic use uh disorder of cannabis
products uh just to make sure that those
uh limitations or health hazards are are
included in those informational handles
particularly with respect to
um potential health hazards uh
associated with use by uh folks that are
breastfeeding or
pregnant doctor maybe we can just copy
the information under
30 on 17 P 17 it shows pretty
specifically over Adent young adults
breastfeeding pregnancy we just sort of
use those same things in this section so
so you're doing 318 f82 and that advice
about potential risks of cannabis that
yeah Mr chair I would also add keep this
product away from children so so
let's so I guess my recommendation is we
leave the language alone in seven and
just look at when we get to the next
page about the information because it
talks about informational materials and
warning labels and we can address it
over and there rather than make an
exhaust some sort of list and under
number seven that sound
reasonable okay see it and then number
eight uh no later than 36 months after
the effective data section the
commission shall make written
recommendation general court regarding
regulations of hemp cabon oids synthetic
avonoids intoxicating products derived
from hemp including and then a list of
ABC and D there um I think this is start
we start talking into this area of Delta
8 and Delta 10 cannabis products that
are derived out of attemp but now are
being synthetically altered um to change
the makeup and so this just says that
they need just they need to give us some
advice the legislature in in a
reasonable amount of time so that we
could potentially put either rules or
laws around that down the road that make
sense we're okay with that
one
okay we're through that section um we
added them nine about the recall and
notifications and that's the end of that
section we're moving on to the next
section on page 1
318 f8 um informational materials and
warning
okay number two um this is the
informational handout and designed by
the commission and consultation depart
with the Department with all cannabis
cannabis products sold to customers so
these are the warning uh warning advice
to handouts if you will as to possible
issues um we see that talks about the
risk of driving adverse uh effects to
you to the youth um and effects of
related to mind development potential
adverse effects of risks including
mental health and risks um for pregnancy
um are some of the big bullet points I'm
sure there may be others that are
contained within the handout especially
with the advice of of uh some of the
handouts we they submitted regarding
labeling
so
is there anything you see that's not
listed here that is a big big line item
we'd want to make sure we
had and not leave it to the rul making
Authority where they'll and the
development
process well maybe we should add a risk
of driving driving well it is right so
that's right under number one if you
look at Roman numeral 2 letter a small I
the risk of driving on an influence eist
in the factor doing so is
illegal yeah perhaps
uh consideration for adding the
potential
penalty uh if convicted for driving
longair under cannabis may be helpful
given the statistical increase in every
state that's commercialized with respect
to the number and increase of serious
bodily injury and fatal motor vehicle
use so we'll put it under the small
Roman numeral eye when it talks about
the risk of driv and just add possible
penties penalties for violation will be
up to kind of language certainly the
easiest way to make it is shorten it up
it's a penalty up to a maximum of
whatever yeah thank you that sound
reasonable everybody yeah yeah okay
anything else yep what Chief suggested
was always go for the highest scary
right right that's I that's we'll use up
to language right up to I don't what the
DWI is now what $1,200 for a possible
maximum fine with penalty assessment and
I think for uh a second offense or or or
aggravated it's 2, or 2400 and up to a
year in jail is the penalty so that
would be the penalties that would be
Influence Mr chair Lieutenant did I get
my numbers right all right good haven't
put a bad ONN in over 20 years but um
anything else Mr chair the only other um
perhaps Gap here would be unless it's
already contained elsewhere uh in the
reference statute under 318 information
with respect to um the health hazards
that may arise from chronic use disorder
which is a a burgeoning problem in the
health industry with respect to cannabis
use um those health effects might be
handout so uh Mr mikica maybe under that
again Roman numeral three under a where
it talks about potential adverse effects
and other risk including mental health
we can talk about chronic use disorder
possibly there you know um reoccurring
use you know whatever the word you want
to use frequent use can result in
of
yeah I think that could go under D it
says you know for um two yeah 2D it says
how to recognize problematic or how to
recognize maybe cannabis use disorder
and how to obtain appropriate surfaces
or
treatment yes that's actually the
language that we had
here so put We'll add that under D that
it will include something around about
of flipping to page on 18 going to e and
continuing
through anything in e or F that anybody
adjust seeing none we'll move on number
three cannabis uh the the commission may
require franchise cannabis retail stores
so I'm gonna I'm just going to fix that
language because we've changed the
definitions um we got rid of one of
those I can't remember which it was um
um and it'll just say the that whe
whether it's franchise cannabis retail
outlets or just cannabis retail stores
shall display informational posters and
conspicuous locations about the risks da
da da everybody okay with that with that
Amendment
four
Tim so you where it says conspicuous I
don't think we want in conspicuous is
that what you were just saying we we
want to put the posters out in the open
no no all I was doing is we have two
definitions of retail stores and we
struck one of them I don't remember
which one we struck we just said they're
cannabis retail stores I think and so in
number three I'm just striking that well
I just wanted to make sure the
informational posters didn't didn't
include the warnings and I don't want
the warnings in a conspicuous location I
want them out in the open where people
warnings conspicuous sounds to me like
it mean I I I'm not an expert but
conspicuous means like kind of hidden
no conspicous is just the opposite of
hidden it means out front very it's easy
to see right if you're conspicous it's
see so we're okay with number three with
the minor adjustment number
four those about warning labels
you Mr chair on a warning label
recommendation we've looked at a number
of warning labels and uh the current
language there um perhaps may not
be scientifically accurate we're looking
at something more broad uh which would
say consumption of this product
intoxicating effect products
intoxicating effects which may be
delayed and impair
the consumer for an undetermined amount
of
time well placing a time limit there
would perhaps be limiting and give a
full sense of
security in fact inaccurate sense of
security to
someone I'm going to turn to the doctor
there for for a good answer again would
I'm not sure if any place else we ever
use this kind of language don't use an
alcohol um about consuming a beer May
create intoxicating effects and Lasting
up to you know we don't use that in any
of our alcohol warning labels I'm a
little I I don't know the signs around
this so I I I think it would be
reasonable just saying may be delayed
and just take out the our language
because that is you know we know that
that's a big problem with Edibles um is
that it's often very delayed and people
just take more and more and that's why
they end up in the emergency room so um
but yeah I think that may be delayed and
like you know yeah I think that that
anything else on five
um I I have a question about um number
four if we could just back up moment um
we were talking about warning labels I
know that we've had discussion about um
inserts that have more comprehensive
information such as what when you get a
prescription drug um
can we um is there another place here
that we're talking about inserts or is
this the appropriate level uh place
number four warning labels or inserts
Andor inserts they we can't put all of
the warnings on a label it's it's not
going to fit we've had that discussion
yet inserts would allow us to um raise
awareness on
multiple um risk factors and harms so I
guess the question that you're really
asking is whether or not when we sell
cannabis to or given will we give again
a warning handout just saying here's in
bigger larger print not just so fine
print on the side of a bottle right or a
side of on the side similar to
interactions with uh prescription drugs
when when we see these when we get these
I happen to read those I I think that
seems very reasonable I I also think
that we shouldn't have language that
says or it should say and there should
be a warning label on everything um in
addition to additional uh information um
or Warnings um and I think we have this
somewhere else but uh I'm not certain
about rotating the inserts like you know
every month it's a different insert so
that we have some uh increase in
education and it's hard to get
everything out there in one shot so can
we add shall include warning labels and
and
inserts so so me back up so again if we
back up one page and we go back to
number number two on the handout um that
we were talking about the handout
specifically says right the we'll fix
the store language there on that first
section with two types of stores we only
have one now but shall include an
informational handout designed by the
commission and consultation of the
department um with all cannabis products
sold so it looks like they're already
planning on handing them a a handout on
cannabis products and the effects and
warnings of that that's a full sheet
type of or a hand or glossy H whatever
they use but um they're on top of
whatever sales stuff I think we're
talking apples and oranges here I think
this is more specific to the substance
for for example if it's a you know a a
uh THC uh edible gummy versus you know
it would be I think be dependent on THC
levels things things along that line but
again not necessarily a brochure this is
more I guess my my general I don't want
to I don't want to pardon me I don't
want to weigh down the department trying
to figure out right hand out for the
right product considering they're all
cannabis products right and they can
include like based on potency this your
effects will be will change right they
can add that kind of language into the
into it but do you really want them to
carry if they have 50 products 50
different handouts well maybe it's maybe
it's just one General handout that's
well that's what I think section two
does it's one General handout that talks
about the effects and and that
and so it'll be include you know
numerous warnings with every sale with
every sale numerous warnings and they'll
get this with every sale correct it's
not something they go to and pick up a
or shore on correct based on number two
it says um okay with all you know shall
be include the information hand out with
all cannabis and cannabis products sold
to Consumers so they have to have a hand
sale in detail world it's called the bag
stuffer so you just put it in has all
the information all the warnings about
everything that is included in the store
for sale so it's a gen it's can be as
general as you'd like it to be or as
specific to individual products as you'd
like it to
be and you're in develop but by Statute
by this you would have to develop that
product and give it give it out at every
sale when
correct thank you
all right
um where were
we Mr chairman on five just a quick
comment uh some of the manufacturers
have have uh contacted us and asked that
the word opaque be removed in d uh and
only because some of this product is
light sensitive and and some of the
product comes in foil packages that have
do you know would have some sort of a
iing on it so that the word opaque be
removed in D that just says child
resistant packaging and then the uh we
could add something we could add an e
that says be packaged in opaque
packaging or placed in an opaque bag at
the time of the sale so in other words
if somebody if if if the idea was we
wanted to see what people were carrying
out or be able to have see what people
were carrying out the bag itself would
be an opaque bag but the individual
packaging of the products due to their
light sensitivity some of them they're
the opaque the actual opaque bag of each
one uh wouldn't be a wise thing for them
I mean I don't know about anybody else I
really don't care whether the package
they carrying out is opaque or not I
think it's important that the product
itself I understand the potency in UV
light all that kind of thing so it makes
sense that the packaging of the product
might be not in a you know Opa package
I don't know we're going go to the
detail of telling you what kind of
package you got to walk out of the store
with a lot of them come in metal tins
yeah that with uh you know the warning
labels on them oil bags with the warning
labels on them so does anybody have a
strong opinion on whether the bag they
carry out of the store is opaque or not
opaque no we'll leave it to you
Chief um good we're done with that
section franchise fee
imposed um we get to the money my fun
part uh um so we're talking about uh the
15% franchise fee on gross monthly sales
we're going to have an interesting
discussion down here because especially
as we're starting the concept of whether
or not we're going to sell medicinal
products or therapeutic products in a
retail store whether that's going to be
taxed or not um or do we say yes all
cannabis is taxed if it's in a retail
store or only um retail recreational
product therapeutic product is untaxed
let's have that discussion I would just
ask uh
Senator that the word tax fee I
apologize thank you appreciate it very
much chair ways it means I always
understood thank you
so we spell p TX in the Hampshire tax
Fe just um regarding the 15% uh tax uh
Dr Lynn silver who testified two weeks
ago from California uh in reading her
material she said that will be
inadequate to counter the um the social
harms law enforcement and um that that
we're going to be needing in so that we
can get it right from the start so why
what my question is is how did we arrive
why well there was there was much
discussion in house Commerce about the
fee whether it be 8% whether would be
20% so the discussion went back and
forth at length and I believe house
Commerce at the time fell on
12% and we uh were
just we testified that we didn't feel
the 12% was enough and that 15% in
running the numbers that we've run 15%
we feel is a fair amount for us
to re retail the product at better
prices than the surrounding states and
still make it a profitable Endeavor for
the state to undertake okay Dr Silva was
saying that um that Revenue would be
inadequate for the state to address the
issues that will arise that have Arisen
in in the legalized States and she was
recommending
30% well uh I think that
the good doctor is from the state of
California where tax doesn't seem to be
a an issue and and is it's they're quite
liberal with their taxes there one would
say and I think that the state of New
Hampshire takes a different approach to
that we feel as business people that 15%
is an adequate fee for the franchisees
to pay in order for it to be profitable
in a state this size and for us to be uh
profitable as a business that intends to
sell product to folks out of state much
like the folks in this state now are now
going to Massachusetts and paying
exorbitant fees and taxes and in Maine
exorbitant fees and taxes and in Vermont
exorbitant fees and taxes so our goal is
to be as reasonable as we possibly can
with the prices in order to keep that
business uh solvent Okay so follow up
follow up uh the profitability we're
talking two two different issues here
profitability for the
franchisees versus revenue for the state
to address the uh social problems that
will inevitably um come our way
regardless of of the retail outlet so I
think we need to be cognizant from the
very beginning that we are going to have
problems we already know that and if we
cannot address those our state our our
children our families our state will
suffer we we're basically playing with
fire here well I may Mr chairman there's
no one at the Liquor Commission that
wants to put anybody In Harm's Way of
anything our our model ensures that and
we just feel as business people that
15% is enough for the state to have have
a profit that ensures that everything
that needs to be done in a state of this
size is adequate just I just have one
more question if I could make this point
if our our surrounding states are have
exorbitant um taxes on this why should
we not play on that Level Playing Field
why should we short Change New Hampshire
citizens
I I don't feel that we are so that's
that's going to be ultimately end up
being a legislative prerogative I
promise you and it shows up in front of
the way it means we're going to have a
big conversation about what the rate is
and what the revenues look like um I'm
going to go back to 1598 from last term
we were estimating about $250 million in
gross sales in the state of New
Hampshire which will result on a 15%
franchise fee of 37.5 millionar of new
revenue for the State of New Hampshire
to combat what's going on so I
uh until we have some data I think $
37.5 million in new Revenue that'll
supplement our Mental Health Services
and and substance abuse services are a
significant number to help U considering
every one of these I won't say everyone
be enough it's
not it gets into the argument of do we
think they're going to be new consumers
or is it just going to be existing
consumers that are already doing a
product and already have the issues to
begin with that we're going to be
working with so I think there's probably
an an inal growth that happens but the
question is what that looks like and
it's not going to be solved in this
committee I promise you um so um let's
come over here Tim the J the Jordan and
then the
chief and then
Dave thank you represent um yes in ways
and means this will get a proctological
exam actually um one of the things that
we will consider in this in Ways and
Means will be the effect on on the black
market which has not been discussed in
here uh states with a high taxation I
know from going to various national
conferences states that have had that
have wound up not competing with the
black market in the black market the
corner salesman with selling whatever
weed he can grow uh winds
up uh under selling the uh the state at
that time which means that you're not
affective ing illegal sales you're not
stopping the black market you're not
stopping tainted product from getting
out but if you can provide a product
that is less expensive and that is
tested in the same fashion that we do
with both cigarettes and with alcohol
today under the program that we have
then you don't have bathtub Jin being
sold you've
got um
beers which isn't bad but
kind of bitter but um that's that's
that's my point and that will be
discussed in ways means okay did didn't
we have some discussion about removing
this 1% uh with the municipalities
because we didn't want to put them at
risk of uh if something happens
federally and they crack down on money
then again so the so right now under the
under this bill um although I think the
we might be talking wrong Chief I I I
think the intent was um not not 1% of
the 15% but a full 1% of the rate of the
fee would go to the retailer because the
way this is written it' be 1% of 15%
which is a really really small number um
and so I think we just need to need to
correct that the idea is the state would
keep 14% the town would get 1% the
state's collecting all 15 though and
then disturbing it back to the town and
I'm assuming when you say Town cheap
you're talking about the community that
hosts the retail store are we talking um
like rooms of meals tax where it just
goes into a pool of money it's
distributed to all towns and all cities
which way is this goes to the individual
towns that have the
stores um da Chief and then
Dave thank you Mr chair um again not
with respect to whether or not I'm
weighing in on the 15% that's either
high or low but in the connection with
what um you mentioned which is the
research and just for the edification
of uh the committee there is a report
out that was issued uh fairly recently
September of 2023 by a rather esteemed
institution that really has no dog in
the fight if you will and that's the
Federal Reserve Bank of Kansas uh that
report is is online and it talks about
um the offset cost which is I think part
of the discussion with respect to your
percentage debate and that offset cost
that the Federal Reserve Bank
estimates uh is
$1,400 per capita which is a rather
large amount so uh perhaps that study
could be used by Ways and Means and um
uh take a look at what the potential
offset costs are uh and that that report
is available online great any discussion
about the uh question Senor Ganon
commissioner you said earlier you said
turn your mic I'm
sorry um commissioner you said you
didn't want to put anyone in harm as way
but if you're increasing sales and the
products got it that time um you said
swing
I think when I was referring to that I
was referring to the the liquor sales
the way we do it the way we're doing
sales now are our model is around
education those stores are controlled
locations and thus being a controlled
State and we feel that the oversight of
the franchisees would also indicate that
they'd be a controlled location that's
senator in regards adds to whatever
amount percentage uh the franchise fee
is I mean we could have a franchise fee
of 30% to 50% but if it's not going to
the right places to offset the H that's
being done my my recommendation would be
that to make sure that whatever fee
comes in that we have a high enough
percentage of it going to mental health
going into the mental health aspect
going into the no I I know but I'm just
saying in relation to this
I I think that's that's the uh Baseline
that we should be looking at no matter
what the fee is that an adequate amount
is going towards offset
so so again I'll just say as a serving
three terms in the house and ways of
means and chair ways of means in our in
our state in the Senate now that the
Hampshire's never been one just to raise
a tax to collect Revenue right there had
the the point of our the tax model is a
to have money to offset any any cost so
the cost of liquor will come out of that
as well um so that there's no to the
general citizenry there's none expense
for this and then the second part is
provide the services that are necessary
but even after we got all that it's not
in the Hampshire's way to just ratchet
the tax up for this cause right for the
sake of just generating revenue for the
general fund so uh I I will say I think
a portion you have to recognize is I
think what the chief was alluding to is
again there's a certain amount of of I'm
going to call it harm reduction um in in
consumers of product if they don't have
to go to the black market because we
have a clean product for lack of a
better phrase that they're consuming we
don't have to worry about kids
overdosing on fentanyl we don't have to
or or adults overdosing on fentanyl um
because they're getting a clean tested
Pro product and I think there's a
certain amount of that and making sure
that the tax and so exorbitant that it
pushes them back to Black Market where
that potential then exists again um um
where um those those adulterated
products can be served because it's
cheaper to go to the black market than
it is to come to the state so it's a
balancing act but for sure um and and I
I don't know whether 15% is the right
number we'll find we'll have this
discussion in ways and means we we
talking about um the fee um but um but
just understand there's a little bit of
a balance act going on there about
reduction of harm by having consumers
move off the black market and come into
the legal market and we had the same
discussion around sports betting when I
put that bill in um about how much we
took away from Black Market and it was
helpful to the industry so or to
Consumers because they couldn't Mr chair
I just want to just make one final point
it all comes down to what's in the
bucket if there's not enough in the
bucket you are not going to be be able
to direct the correct amount to offset
the risks in the hubs that's that's all
I'm saying all right so we're done on
that one moving on uh 318 F10 um so the
only change I had in that last section
by the way was I'm going to clean up
that language around the 1% of 15% to
make sure it's clear that they get a
full 1% of the tax that's collected and
the removal of the word opaque and a
removal of the word opaque on that was
in the previous section yeah okay um and
it's a fee not a
tax corre it says
tax little side note Mr J you were
saying that we don't tax products to
make money so much I know you're saying
$6 to800 million from banking off of
alcohol isn't to make Revenue well no
I'm not saying it's it's absolute but we
just don't do it for the sake of doing
it is what I'm saying
um all right moving on uh residency
requirement um accept as provid in the
section any person applying for a
cannabis establishment license shall be
a resident or shall have at least one
director offic or partner who was in a
Hampshire resident yeah Mr chair just
one recommendation here uh establishes
and maintains this would prohibit
someone from establishing a residence
just for the purposes of getting a
license and then not maintaining
residency I think the intent here is to
ensure that the individual establishes
and maintains residents in the state of
New
Hampshire so I I'm not sure your
question because the way this is written
that's what it says you have to be an
Hampshire resident to request a license
or one officer must be a resident well
it says it says establishment doesn't
say maintain so you establishment is the
is the facility establish established
residency it says a cannabis
establishment license a person applying
for an establishment license so we're
talking about the person sell sell
establish a residence but doesn't say
that they should that they're required
to maintain a residence that's what I'm
recommending to establish a residence
okay number two anybody have so we all
set with Section 10 on residency
requirement
okay
um 318
F1 alcohol infused cannabis products
compensation I think this section was
just put into place so we we didn't have
uh there is there is many products out
in the market now that are uh cannabis
infused drinks and we wanted to make
sure that those weren't allowed to be
sold in the state that was the goal
behind it there's cannabis vodkas
there's
cannabis uh
cocktails
beers so so I will say this and and this
is going to be an important section in
the future so in October I was invited
by the beer distributors to to sit on a
panel out in Las Vegas to discuss THC
infused beverages um and what regulatory
requirements we had someone from
Massachusetts Wisconsin that that did
this and I was on a panel to discuss it
um to to the Distributors um
and I in one of the benefits of that was
I got to go on the trade floor to see
all the new products that are coming out
one in four um products that were
beverages um in that was a THC infused
drink whether it was alcohol or whether
it was non-alcohol related um basically
think th you know cannabis infus THC
infused Red Bull you know kind type of
products that were one in four of the
products were THC infused beverages so
as we talk about this I'm with this is
specifically talking about alcohol but
how do we I I don't I don't remember
reading anywhere how are we going to
deal with other products that are th
infused
beverages we're just going to treat them
as regular edible products and leave it
at that or this is specifically about
alcohol but these there were a
significant portion of the products that
were on they were not alcoholic drinks
they were just THC fused
beverages jar uh yeah and I'm I'm kind
of curious too
because this seems like this could the
way it's written now could lead to a
problem where things are legal
everywhere else in the country or
everywhere where it's currently
legalized but then it's illegal in New
Hampshire because I I'm assuming the
Liquor Commission isn't going to sell
these products because it's it's sort of
like across of the
two The Liquor Commission also doesn't
want these franchise stores selling
alcohol right so I it seems to me like
this is this is going to create uh
people are going to be buying these in
Maine or New Hampshire Vermont I mean
massachus Vermont whatever coming across
the border like it just seems like we
this is something we should probably
flesh out how are we going to handle it
in terms of you get caught with it is it
going to be illegal so if you got caught
with a I don't know a beer infused with
cannabis are you going to get arrested
in the state of New Hampshire like how
is that going to be all
handled well I think you know what this
was done how this was written was kind
of a general outline much like uh we
don't sell beer in the liquor stores so
if if we wanted to allow the franchisees
to sell cannabis infused drinks or
perhaps cannabis infused beer not
alcohol beer malt beverage or drinks
that's something that we certainly could
add to their license and something that
they could sell if that's the wish of
the legislature to do that alcohol would
be another cannabis infused vodka for
instance would be something different
that the Liquor Commission would have to
look at being that we're the sole uh
retailer of
alcohol so we certainly don't want them
selling a cannabis infused alcohol when
we don't allow anyone else to sell
alcohol malt beverage is different and
and I I can further Define that malt
beverage and or Spirits beverage under
the 6% most of these are Under the 6% so
they would fall under the purview of a
beer distributor Distributing them to
the fr
franchisee and the Liquor Commission
that I just wanted to point out that
there are dry counties still in the
United States of America so just because
alcohol is
sold everywhere there are still places
where it's not sold you
know and some very good alcohol comes
from a very dry county in
Tennessee um so again I I
guess I agree with the other issue is
around um their federal license right so
is there an issue around the federal
alcohol license ttb or something like
that that they have to get they're not
allowing cannabis to be infused if you
licenses and I don't know if it applies
to beer or not I'm not sure it's
something we could look into but I I'm
just to your point of going to the to
the event in Las V Vegas this is a huge
Emerging Market we certainly wouldn't
want the state to if if if it's the goal
of the legislature to make sure that
we're competitive with other states we
certainly wouldn't want these products
not to be available in the state if that
was the goal and if they were available
in the state then they should fall under
the umbrella of the controlled Market of
the light of the
franchisee not in uh every corner store
concern a couple a couple comments I I
think that um responding to
representative svin I I think that the
you know as it stands this is it's it's
not for possession of or consumption of
um it's for us to like manufacture uh
you know import or sell um so if you
were to buy this in Massachusetts and
bring it home to New Hampshire that
shouldn't be a problem from I I wouldn't
think um but I think if we're talking
about in other parts of the bill um not
combining cannabis with other drugs like
nicotine or anything else this is sort
of the exact same thing um from a public
safety standpoint and you know certainly
the medical literature shows that the
combination of cannabis and alcohol
together have a you know additive
influence on uh dri or driving um
impairment so I I think we would caution
against having that be at least the
combination of a of an alcoholic
beverage um as being Something That
We're
offering yeah I'm just concerned of how
like you know um to do to the doctor's
point it's true that this is written as
like manufacturing import whatever but
if you get if somebody would be caught
with with that in the state do we just
ignore that and I don't know if it's
clearly laid out in here but I think
that that's something we we should
address because we don't want that to be
some sort of weird loophole for
legalizing something and then suddenly
this product is illegal to manufactur
here so you get caught with it you are
arrested or something I that's just my
concern that that could be sort of a
back door way to arrest people for
something that shouldn't be and maybe
it's fine I don't know what you would
arrest them for because they're not in
violation of any statute if we legalize
marijuana with THC and cannabis is legal
and alcohol is already legal in New
Hampshire so there would be no violation
of law if someone was in possession of a
cannabis infused beer um right so in the
Hampshire there's no law you a police
officer could possibly charge a that's
good point yeah
so would in reading this it appears it
would be like picking up a six-pack and
mass and driving it up to a campground
same same thing it doesn't apply unless
you're manufacturing Distributing or
selling then you're in violation
otherwise you're not in violation so
there's no and I guess my point I want
to make it semi clear that um those THC
infused beverages that are non-alcoholic
in nature may come to our Market but the
question is I want to make sure they're
sold my franchise stores and not
in you know the cumin Farms right so we
sold they should be a regulated market
within our within our franchise stores
if you're going to do a THC infused
beverage I just um as I read this then
um craft breweries in New Hampshire
would be prohibited from um
manufacturing and selling THC infused
products correct correct okay the way
this is written right now I just want to
say I think the intens uh intensifying
the intoxication that that's a public
health issue and public safety issue
with um you know combination of whether
it be M be beverages beer Spirits it's
that's a significant concern so it
sounds like from the conversation we're
okay with the section we're going to
leave it alone Chief I just do want to
talk about um at some Point make sure in
the bill we deal with those non
non-alcoholic cannabis infused drinks
and making sure that my opinion is those
are sold in re in our franchise stores
stores sorry Mr chairman we do have a
reference to that as the chief just
explained to me RSA
uh in title 13 so we can include that
language in this if You' like
happy to do that thank you so we're good
with number f11 going on to
system so Chief I assume this is what's
commonly known as um seed to seed to
shelf
tracking
yes um I apologize in an earlier section
I missed something that new Futures had
lifted up from a public health
perspective so I was wondering when it's
when it's appropriate if we could go
back to um 318 f8 and just have new
Futures come up for a second let's
finish the tracking and then we because
we already propped that up and we'll go
back change you want are we okay with
system great all right Frank what was
the change you wanted to go back to what
Dave turn your mic
on
the tracking system now that just joged
something on my my mind here going back
to the ID section I know this has to do
with inventory but if if we're not
taking people's names and there's no
record if somebody buys marijuana and
I'm not saying I'm in favor of of doing
that but if we have a no matter what um
what limit we have whether it's two or
four uh ounces of uh marijuana
what what would be in place to stop
somebody from going to a store in
Manchester hypothetically and then go in
a conquer in getting eight
ounces and I'm just curious do we have
any safeguards with that it's or is it
just like a lick store where you you
could
just let me turn that back on so first I
am going to make one change to the
section and I'm going to add the word
product tracking system because we're
not talking about tracking people in
this language we're talking about
tracking the product product from seed
to sale to making sure we we can account
for anything for whatever reason but not
including the actual sale right seed to
shelf is really the the title um but so
I'm going to add I'm just going to
change 12 to read product tracking
system so it's clear what we're tracking
I understand that I read the I read that
but it just goes back to the earlier
section where we uh talked about not
taking anybody's Identity or
identification or anything is would
really be no stopping anybody they could
go to every single store and I'm just
curious is there anything liquor does
regular investigations I understand from
people who are buying alcohol in large
quantities and moving it about and so
I'm sure this would fall under that same
kind of idea is that um they would tra
you know to a certain extent if if a if
they see somebody coming in on a regular
basis I'm sure it'll trigger some sort
of Investigation
somewhere but hard hard hard to do
illegal well that's what that that's
what other other states I I believe do
do that but and that's how they're able
to if somebody goes into one store stops
them from buying more at another
store well as with alcohol you can if
someone wants to someone buys a bottle
in Manchester and drives to colbrook and
you know is at an event and the event
runs out and that person goes to a store
in colbrook in the same day there's
there's no tracking of that and this
would be this would be the same in any
of the we don't we don't track anything
as far as what people buy in in the
liquor
stores okay just
one Jim that record there I just wanted
to say we we do track that people buy
firearms and having marijuana and
Firearms at the same time is definitely
punishable
ferally so we're getting a little bit
off off kilter from what the actual
title is right again we're talking about
product tracking right here we can come
back and see if there's something else
if there's things missing we come back
to the idea of identification uh
information again right now the only
reason we would look at someone's
identification is to validate H and then
give it back and we would not record
that data per the bill Chief just one uh
um perhaps consideration on the third
line
adding tracking the
cultivation uh manufactur transfer um um
I'm not sure whether or not um that's
needed but to certainly make sure that
uh the tracking starts from the time
cultivated yeah I I think they they were
being a little all-inclusive because
they just said anytime you trans transer
product from one license to another
license lead it's got to be tracked so
whether you're moving from a cultivator
to a manufacturer the product has to be
tracked and I'm assuming somewhere in
rules they'll have they're going to deal
with cultivators and quantity they
cultivate you know reg regulations
around cultivation and quantities so
they purchasing of seeds what happens if
they have Surplus where that goes and
that all that will be done in rule so
all that'll be tracked under other
parts okay moving on to
um f13 Mr sorry yes
she I was could we go back to um oh y
good uh f8 it' be okay to have Kate come
up from new futures for a second thanks
so f8 just remind you this is um around
warnings thank you I appreciate this um
just a couple points I wanted to point
out during the warning label um an
information section I think one thing
that the commission really should
consider um is prevention strategies in
terms of the latest information we have
from the uh National Poison Control
Center and the New Hampshire Poison
Control Center we're seeing a 1400%
increase Nationwide on
ingestions since uh
2017 um not to say that's a good thing
or a bad thing as far as whether
commercialization should come into the
state but we have really uh learned
learned a lot about prevention practices
um one thing to consider is plain
packaging of edible products I know that
there's a lot of nuances there as
presented by the commission another
thing that could be considered is uh
what we are learning a lot of success
from our prevention Partners In the
state especially those who are bordering
um states that are legal is the use of
uh medication lock boxes um where
parents families they have these uh
tools to lock up any cannabis products
that may be loose especially Edibles and
appealing to kids um what we have
suggested is that um retail sales have
for sale um medication lock boxes these
have been proven to be a really
successful tool with as we know
prescription drugs um now we're seeing
it more with cannabis um again it would
be a requirement for those stores to
sell those products just like we would
have those information materials there
about locking up your products have
those there too um there are you know
again different prevention strategies
that we learn um and with cannabis this
is what we've um found has been
successful so that's a suggestion um
from new Futures that I think can be
really workable and a very creative
approach Mr mik so again um I know we
talked about requirements of having a
that every franchise store sell um a
lock box a medication lock box and I
don't know where maybe you can tell us
next meeting where in the rules we think
we should put that
requirement happy to do that Mr
chairman all
right so we're on to enactment of
Municipal ordinance say
13 Chief so on on this particular one
there perhaps needs to be a couple of um
change minor changes here uh to ensure
we're we're looking at an opt-in and non
oped out process and that would be
striking the reference to the election
held in November of
24 and then later on where it reflects
July 1 to 25 and perhaps consider
language that should say prior to the
approval of any licensed establishment
to manufacture cultivate or sell
cannabis product in that
municipality right um that uh it goes
forward from there that the licensing
should be um approved by the
municipality uh in advance and conformed
to whatever the municipality loaning
zoning ordinances may be just to ensure
that we have an opt-in provision here
out I believe that the nhma also sent
correspondence to Senator abbis on that
point as
13th Mr chair I I think that's a very
let's talk about section one first right
so this is strictly the opin provision
um whether the town was I agree we
should strike the words held in November
24 and just say at the banal election
period right because obviously no one's
going to put it on the November 24
ballot by by the time we're done not
sure we'll have a law by then um but
um so what we can strike held in
November 24 and just say it has to be on
every two years is your option to opt in
for a town um is every two years
wording interesting because in theory
you could they're asking for two
separate questions on this ballot one of
which is do1 operation of cannabis
establishments which could be any
licensed type whether it's um
conservation manufacturer or
retail um but then the second one is
specifically to um
retail
um yes Mr chair that's one passes in the
other
yeah confusing um having both of those
anybody I think it's critical to keep
the op language there only because with
the therapeutic cannabis local control
was something that was completely um
non-existent and so we want to make sure
that the towns are my question is we
have two different questions that would
be on the same ballot which in theory
you could pass one and fail the other
one for some reason okay um and it's
kind of confusing you're saying yes we
want cist establishments but then you're
saying yes also we want retail
establishments either or two and so I
think it should be I I would do away
with the second question altogether just
say should we allow the operation of
Cabas establishments within the town
period end of story that's the question
on yeah and then it's clear that it
could be anything it could be a
cultivation a manufacturer distributor
or a retail store but it's cannabis
establishment does that make sense to
everybody Jordan yes that makes sense
but at the same time you've got two
different types of activities taking
place one is Agricultural and the other
is
retail so your your zoning would have to
uh take those into consider we get the
zoning which is in the second piece
right so the first piece is is strictly
about the opin provision and I think we
just have one question and says shall we
allow the operation of Canabis
established within the city or town
period right and then strike the next
question and then the rest of it still
um I think that's good point and then
there that's starting even the
um the signal approv the operation and
Council session may start applying for
approval on July 1 I I tend to get rid
of that myself because the second half
of this is municipalities need time if
they opt in to write zoning ordinances
to deal with the fact that they're now
allowing it they need zoning ordinances
to go along with it so I I I would like
to strike that se that July 1 date and
just you know precisely because you're
you're hamstringing what the the time
corre I think we can strike everything
from right again after that second
question if all the way down to the
date right I don't know that we have to
put any timeline into um their approval
processes passes and then can start
applying with planning board but they
place and then there's a recount
procedure which is typical municipality
recount
processes and there's a clear language
that obviously if my town town of sanon
decided it wasn't going to legalize any
c Canabis establishments it still means
I can drive through the town of sanon
Interstate 93 to get to to North Country
with C prod get so that's not that's not
in
zoning any questions about
this comments again this just allows
local municipalities to set zoning
restrictions there are some zoning
requirements in the next section we're
going to talk about about schools um
that will preempt local zoning um but
this is allows for them to designate
only allowed in our Comm commercial Zone
kind of thing
so agricultural only in the agricultural
Zone they write those rules nothing on
number section two so we're good there
um 318 F14 restrictions on location near
schools I will tell you I've got lots of
conversation about this um the 2,000 ft
seems to be extremely exclud uh makes it
so they're going to be in some towns you
could never do it because they have so
many schools um that you would never be
able to have a facility in there even if
they voted to allow one um the
recommendation was to look at other
statutes where we have zoning ordinances
around usually it's vape shops and
pornography around schools and churches
um and use similar language as that um
and Sim similar distances to that but
conversation yes Mr chair thank you um
we would recommend that in addition to
schools that we also include community
colleges colleges or
universities uh in in this uh particular
section particularly since uh the
majority of those folks fall within
the time uh the age frame of of being
exposed um from a public health
perspective at
risk so your recommendation Chief is to
include
colleges um in the distance restriction
from possible cannabis retail loc
cannabis locations community colleges
universities right comments on that
Chief Joe U Mr chair uh title 13 section
1771 has to do with state liquor stores
and that is that no newly established
state store shall be operated within 200
feet of any public or private school
church chapel or Parish
record Parish I think the parish is a
large area it includes entire
towns well I think
they're excuse me represent it says
Parish
house thank
you I was to say uh 200 feet is
inadequate I think with with cannabis I
I I know that uh the city of lonia has
had some issues with a vape shop that's
just right um within site and shouting
distance of this school so I don't think
that that would be adequate 200 feet it
would stay with the 2,000 feet just for
the record I'm I'm not a proponent I'm
just of yeah what footage it is I'm just
2,000 feet uh to your point would
exclude many cities and towns from
having a a cannabis location and I was
just referring to the statute for lior
not suggesting that it should be 200t
might need to so also understand
municipalities would have the right of
the zoning organes to change it within
their own zoning and cultural needs so
again Isa e and samon we have the state
of wetland setback and we've chosen to
increase our Wetland setback beyond what
the state minimum requirement is because
we protect our Watershed even more so
municipalities would always have the
right to do zoning ordinances that were
beyond the restriction of the state if
they chose to if they wanted to allow it
but there's Zing one says you can only
do it within 500 ft of a school they
could choose to do that but the question
is as a state do we want to set a
minimum standard that you can't no town
can go below this number you could go
above it but you can't go below it
that's the question
Frank um I agree with trying to figure
out a I mean I think functionally this
this would put many many municipalities
out of the option so I as you mentioned
there's already an not only
um um um control that municipalities
would have but they're also going to
have to opt in so they're going to have
to you know affirmatively say yes we
want this in our town so there's
multiple ways if a town has concerns for
them to not let this happen in their
jurisdiction um so I think just from a
practical perspective I think mirroring
it on you know what what L mentioned
makes more sense so my recommendation
would be is that we leave the the first
everything to the common no cannabis of
sou shall operate and then incorporate
177 71 which is the 200 ft Church
schools and everything else that that is
in that so again remember the same group
of officers are going to be enforcement
so having as much consistent enforcement
is going to be important so we'll
reference we'll copy the language from
that other chapter and put that in here
as the minimum standard and then allow
towns to establish greater standards if
they want to beyond the minimum standard
of the state that sound reasonable
everybody no I I don't like the I don't
like
right all right lawful operation of
cannabis
facilities Mr chair just uh and
addressing the potential loophole here
for Black Market under uh
subparagraph small
a uh perhaps uh to tighten this up it
should read possessing displaying
transporting cannabis or cannabis
products that are cultivated
manufactured sold pursuant to this
chapter uh that makes it clear that it
separates it from anyone who's doing it
otherwise inconsistent with the chapter
I'm sorry where where do what do you
want to change um uh write uh small a
yeah first line possessing displaying
transporting cannabis or cannabis
products and then add that are
cultivated manufactured or sold pursuant
chapter that makes it clear that there's
a distinction between um cannabis
products that are not being transported
sold or produced pursuant to this
chapter which are obviously tracked and
uh part of the process from that which
or to shorten it up you could simply say
cannabis products um uh sold pursuant to
this
chapter so this is relative to
lenses right and it's just saying that
it's not illegal if you're a lcy to do
these things well if you go to number
one it says if undertaken by a person 21
years of age or older doesn't reflect
lense a uh shall not be
illegal uh for the basis of seizure
forfeiture under New Hampshire law
possessing displaying or transporting
well
essentially uh what we want to do here
is make sure that there's not a loophole
for illicit Market by simply making
making sure that you're referencing that
those products sold pursuant to the
chapter
Mr chair so if
I so again I think Chief the if you go
down to line 37 on the page right so
everything you start off with a with a
list right was saying it shall not be
legal for the following we have a list
of of events um but we're talking about
again two a to a testing facility from a
cannabis product manufacturing
um so I'm trying to understand where you
think a loophole is well I'm just making
sure that you have tight language here
and when it comes to Prosecuting people
or stalking people from a practical
standpoint on the road right uh or
litigating a case um and again we have
attorneys here from the Attorney
General's office they may disagree but I
think language here that simply says
that you're referring to products made
uh sold under this chapter makes it very
clear what you're talking about it
Mr chair y I think I understand where
the chief's coming he wants to have when
he goes to court an ability to say this
person was acting illegally because he
had a non-licensed product and the only
way and only methodology of doing that
is to put into the law that only New
Hampshire
lenses are subject to this because
reading this and I agree with the chief
reading this I could
have I'm over 21 by more than one
day
marijuana grab it and sell it under this
chapter because it says it's not
illegal even though I'm not
licensed to do
so so you need to make somewhere in
there that this
is Deals Only with New Hampshire lenses
and it's a belt and suspenders type of
activity but it certainly makes it
easier for the chief or any of the uh
Leos here to so Joe are you following
this because I'm I'm honestly I'm not
quite following the loophole they're
thinking about but if you're following
it would you propose language that
closes whatever perceived loophole
they're looking at
here oh I think we could on line
37 we could add
licensed from a licensed cannabis
product
manufacturing facility or sale delivery
so licensed cannabis it falls under the
The Heading lawful operation of cannabis
related facilities but if you wanted to
fur further clarify it in line 37 you
cannabis
going do the same thing in front of the
Cannabis testing facility a licensed
cultivator but probably also or license
sale delivery or distribution gabis or
cannabis products to an adult who is 21
years of
old that that's where I think that's
about so I think that I think the what
they're really trying to get at is if if
I'm a transporter or cultivator and I'm
moving product to a manufacturer I'm
going to be above the 2 ounce 4 ounce
model limit we have and that's not
illegal if I'm conducting it in the form
of business is what we're trying to say
I think that's what this chapter is
trying to say is that you're not subject
to the same 2 ooun or 4 ounce
restriction whatever it is
okay all right look at that we could add
there it's one of those one of those
legal sentences that go on forever and
you're trying to understand what it
means because they got so much precursor
to
it but actually Mr chairman you could
add it to The Heading lawful operation
of licensed cannabis retail facilities
put it in the heading and then it would
include everything would have to be
so just thinking of the statutory
construction here the the title appears
to refer to to cannabis related
facilities then the the prohibition or
the designation that certain acts shall
not be illegal doesn't specify that as
well and then there's the list of
different uh types of conduct or
activities that would not be illegal so
I if I'm understanding the chief's
concern one of those the first one um
and all of these would be different
Clauses separated by the semicolons
would be simply possessing displaying or
transporting cannabis or cannabis
products and there isn't any language
necessarily here that would be
prohibiting that independent of a
cannabis related facility the title
refers to cannabis related facility but
the the statutory language itself would
say anybody 21 years or older it shall
not be illegal to possess display or
transport cannabis or cannabis products
I think that that the chief's concern
would be that doesn't exclude the
possibility of black market products
being being included as as not illegal
under this section so trying to insert
language uh that would clarify that
products are operation consistent with
uh
this uh this this title would be would
not be illegal but operation outside of
of the title would be
illegal if I'm understanding that the
chief's concern so Joe I'm going to ask
you to go review this see if we can
tighten it up and make it a little
cleaner language there's way too many
semicolons to try to understand the list
of of what we're doing I think again the
clear answer is that in operation of a
licensed facility the following act
shall not be you know illegal right for
a person 21 or older and it's it might
be an easier way of saying it than
trying what we're doing here we're
breaking up in all kinds of different
sections so um well let's skip that
section and come back after the chief
reviews it taking in what we said
um about about um the lawful operation
again so just rewrite that section and
maybe tighten it up so it's a little
cleaner in understanding so we don't
have Miss the statutory construction I
just said it's
better we just we're skipping over um 21
22 all right proof of purchase identity
purchaser's
identity
um so again this is interesting as we
have a different standard than we just
used in the other one about government
ID so we probably want to clean that up
um this is again what's required for a
per person purchasing cannabis from a
franchise location what they're
obligated to show upon request so the
first one is a list you know your ID
whether it's driver's license military
card um passport whatever right um You
have to upon have upon request you have
um second one is it's got to have an
it Mr chair yes uh if I could ask um The
Liquor Commission you already have a
standard for uh buying
alcohol could we not just apply that
here instead of repeating a second set
of
language
certainly so do we just so the question
is do you have I I don't know where that
is in law um but if it's in law we can
just maybe just reference shall be
subject to and reference the other RSA
again so we have one consistent standard
for purchasing alcohol or cannabis above
the age of
21 yeah I think and that would also make
it uh uh from a law enforcement point of
simpler right so we're going to leave
that one alone the chief will come back
with the homework assignment to what
language he wants to change to make it
consistent with the liquor laws for
purchasing liquor improve of identific
that all right um enforcement activity
verifying
non-compliance
um it shall be a violation to sell any
cannabis cannabis product or cannabis
paraphernalia two of mine are during
enforcement activity initiated solely
for the purpose of verifying
non-compliance so again Chief are we
here solely for the purpose of a
verifying
non-compliance that sounds like we're
doing a buy attempted buy for someone
under 21 or something on a retail at a
there just like we do alcohol now we do
that with liquor now to retail stores
with for
beer
yeah Mr chair if if it's re if it points
only to the sale at a uh licensed retail
outlet that's one thing but if if it has
a more broader
implication right with respect to sale
of miners our recommendation is that if
the state is going to legalize
commercialize cannabis that any sale to
a minor of any cannabis product should
be a criminal offense we're talking
about a second violation for smoking in
public being a criminal defense that any
sale of a minor under
21 should be a criminal offense uh
simply because uh of
the substantial health risk imposed to
young people here um and the evidence is
clear in that regard and we need to have
stri
penalties um enhanced penalties with
respect to sale or distribution to a
minor so if I'm if I'm reading this
right and and with the correct reference
to 38 to 318 again this is talking about
enforcement on licensed providers right
people working within the law but not
actually following the law so to speak
um that they're licens is sell but they
don't check the ID and they sell to a
minor right I think other than that if
you were a non-licensed then you sold
you would be take with possession with
intent to sell right you would would be
charged on the existing statute it still
would make it illegal because you're not
a lensee and you're not allowed to sell
marijuana unless you're a l so you be
you would be under the controlled
substance act and be subject to sale and
a felony level if you're a non-licensee
selling
marijuana so I don't know that this this
is strictly talking about lies who don't
comply and sell to an underage minor
just like retail stores who sell beer to
a a 20-year old right that this is
enforcement of those actions and so the
question I'm try that's the way I'm
reading it Chief it's that the
enforcement actions to verify that the
lenses are doing what they're supposed
to do and certainly if if if F col 17
points to Simply sell at a retail outlet
uh then I would agree however uh again
um it's a violation not a criminal
offense to do that uh and perhaps a
recommendation to include elsewhere
somewhere in the recommending statutory
language where appropriate perhaps at
this section that any sale or
distribution to a minor under 21 would
be a criminal
offense at least that's a recommendation
Senor Whitley yeah so I would agree
Senator Lang with your interpretation
that this is this section in particular
is targeted towards enforcement under
this act of the
um involving the
franchisees uh so we already have
existing law on on uh drug related
crimes and so I think that law is
already there we don't need to change
that but I would agree that this is
focused on sort of the enforcement
within the sort of structure that we're
that we're creating so my understanding
of of where it's placed is similar to
yours so Joe can you explain I'm trying
to understand the first sentence and the
second sentence and what the difference
is between them um one talks about um
you know it's a violation
um cannabis product to a minor enfor um
during enforcement activity initiated
solely for the purpose of varing
verifying non-compliance so again that's
a sting operation as I'm reading that be
a violation for a a lensed uh cell to a
minor um if you were doing a sting
operation the second sentence it shall
be a misdemeanor to knowingly sell
cannabis or cannabis paraphernalia canab
par Canabis paraphernalia to a minor at
the time of any such enforcement
activity those two sentences seem in
conflict with each other one saying it's
a violation the other saying it's a
misdemeanor but it seems like it's the
same exact thing and I don't understand
what we're trying to say there can I ask
question does the first one not require
knowledge just the mere fact like if you
took a fake ID and you were real casual
by taking fake IDs for the other one the
second sentence requires knowledge yeah
exactly there's a different intent
you're right you're right yep is that is
that the interpretation Mr chairman I
would ask the chief uh if he's
here come up and speak is he
there so there's a higher essentially I
think C Again State I get it exactly so
there's a
higher first one's if it's a mistake
fake ID oops we didn't do due diligence
secondly is we knew we were doing
it
do we want the CH do you want Mark to
come over and answer some
questions Chief armanian have a seat
raise your right hand no I'm just
kidding thank you
you so Chief we're looking at um page 23
section 17 uh 318 f17 and that first
sentence in the second sentence and I
think we got the answer is one talks
about a sting operation I think where
you send somebody in with either a fake
ID or something like that who who is
under 21 and has a fake ID and they
still sell to him and not identify the
fake ID that would be a violation can
can I correct you on that sir go ahead
no I appreciate it yeah so we don't do
that okay um trickery isn't part of our
Mantra um we do use underage buyers with
their
IDs um what we find is people don't
check IDs so they look at a real ID of
somebody of Youth full age um usually in
the area of s 17 years old 16 to 17
years old and they don't check the ID
there's no fake IDs coming in or
anything because actually that would be
a ense wouldn't it if somebody had a
really good fake ID how would the
establishment be liable for a fake ID so
so which TR understand the difference
between SE the first sentence and the
second sentence one's a violation the
other one's a misdemeanor we're trying
to understand what the difference is why
you would charge one is a violation one
is a misdemeanor but looks like the same
minor except one as a knowing yeah if
you look on line
six the misdemeanor is for knowingly
selling
it so it's going toward culpable state
of mind right I would have to research
F18 um just to get a better view of that
it won't take me long to research it but
sorry I'm coming in cold on this right
now so we'll leave it as it is unless we
have something we come back with
something different that explains you
know but we'll leave it as it is but CH
you can look at it and let us know come
back next week and just I or I could do
it right now if you just give me
to talk about 18 next after this one
okay let me just let me just jump out
fire it up on the computer and research
it and I'll get right back to you so by
default we'll leave it alone unless the
chief comes back with something
different does that sound reasonable to
everybody um I did have one question is
and I think I'm okay with it because
again we don't specify A or B misdem
meter and that is multiple offenses
where you have a a facility that
continually sells and you have license
suspension issues and that kind of thing
possibly but um the question is on a
criminal charge does a second offense
have an increased penalty and my argu I
guess i' argue the same thing I was
talking about consumption if we just
leave it as misdemeanor you always have
the option of filing it as a a versus a
b um if you choose
to for a second offense or multiple
offenses so I'm okay with it as it's
written thanks Chief thank you Senator
all right 318b uh 318f um 18 uh driving
Miners and and control of
property
um I'm sorry may I ask a clarification
question so so you're good with the
language being as is on in section 17
because the uh the misdemeanor can be
charged the first time is an a second
time is a b something like that well
actually would be the yeah first or
second or third time could be charges an
a right so got it based on the
aggravating mitigating so Circumstance
the prosecut have discretion
y um all right section 18
um all of
property section one does anybody have
any comments on section
one Senator just note uh representatives
from the Department of Safety are here
uh may wish to share commentary on
section one sure Lieutenant you want to
up
so again the first F number one is just
saying that nothing in here legalizes
driving Under the Influence I that's a
pretty clear statement of fact we're
good Lieutenant you okay with that
sir section two um nothing in this
chapter shall be construed to permit the
transfer of cannabis with or without
renumeration to a person under the age
or allow a person uh under the age of 21
to possess years again makes it a
statement of fact very clear
that in under no circumstance can a
person of Mone under 21 have have
possession of marij one or can you give
them possession marij
one by Min um number three nothing this
chapter shall Pro the state or County
Correction Facility from prohibiting The
Possession consumption or use display
transfer distribution and
sale Transportation or growing of
cannabis on or in a correctional
facility so again I think this um just
says that the state has the right to say
we don't want any drugs in our jail even
if it is legal just like to do
alcohol one cool question I apologize on
the previous one um and I think this
will depend it may depend on how we end
up dealing with the medical is under 21
with medical
uh yeah I don't know the answer to that
question is therapeutic
18 what is therapeutic any
age um so does that mean we have to add
accept as provided by
yep so but for number one it's
irrelevant right so yeah I think just
number two number one it's irrelevance
only number two right we're talking
about except as
provided accept is permitted permitted
by
Yeah by 126
DX impressive that you have that
statutory reference at your fingertip
sorry talking about marijuana way too
much
um we're okay with three though jails
prohibit um number four accept Prov in
the section this chapter does not
require any personal operation own
controls to allow consumption private
sale
right so again this is talking about uh
private property rights right allowing
allowing private property owner to
restrict if they choose to um the first
one is interesting it it allows a
landlord if they're only doing Edibles
then there should be no reason a
landlord should be able to prohibit it
but obviously can prohibit smoking like
they can now anyway right even you
landlords can prohibit make non-smoking
rentals
so
yep just to be clear now what you're
saying is that even if it is in a zoned
area the owner of the property say just
picking a name of the solivan Brady or
Meg Properties or whatever and say no
can say no smoking marijuana in our
facilities yes smoking in can they
prohibit the sale
of
um in theory
yes that says consumption doesn't say
yeah it does it says sale consumption
cultivation displayed so I'm going to
use the example of Market Basket right
now right so down in Nashua Nash Salem
there was a Char gaming operation wanted
to go into a market Bas basket owned
facility in Market Basket says we don't
want that operation in our state they're
allowed to do
that so this would give them the same
right if a if a strip mall owner and
someone wants to come in with a retail
franchise operation they would have the
right to say no yeah I don't want that
in my strip M just as long as we're
clearing
that is there anything in or we need to
about oh
again
and then C which is under again number
four C on this one b
b again just restates that a landlord
has the right to prohibit smoking or
cultivation within his facility um and
then uh C is interesting it says that if
you're basically visiting somebody that
don't they have the right to stop you
from smoking in their residents or place
to everybody good with that for property
rights great let's go on to enforcement
of contracts
19 um contracts related to the
operation I'm sorry just before moving
off this section uh just like to go back
to subsection one um and I know that we
we touched on it that's relating to um
nothing shall be construed to permit
driving the influence of drugs or liquor
um even without changing anything in
265a uh would just uh ask if uh
the by the operation of this this title
and legalization uh just comment from
the lieutenant on challenges for
enforcement uh related to this as we've
had a lot of other discussion related to
uh Public Health Public Safety uh and so
even though this language is is cursory
and saying we're not touching 265a just
challenges from other sections of law if
we are legalizing or authorizing certain
or want to use different locations so we
just put that to the lieutenant for uh
to ask about uh challenges for
enforcement yeah certainly um so
obviously if we legalize marijuana here
in New Hampshire we're going to have um
an increase in potential uh impaired
driving with this as we've seen
throughout the country with the
increases of impaired driving with um
cannabis related um driving um that
being said some of the things and some
of the challenges is that um we as the
state police are going to see and
probably our local partners and our
County Partners are going to see is um a
training um piece with our with our
Troopers officers and deputies out there
um we're looking probably to have to
increase our um uh education as far as
it goes with um standardized field
sobriety test um getting more testing
and so forth and officers Troopers and
deputies educated in um field sobriety
that would be um able to be utilized for
um um the detection of uh canons with
impaired driving um the other aspect of
it too is something called aide um which
is Advanced roadside impairment
detection um education um that we're
hoping to be able to then um teach to
all of our Troopers officers and
deputies out there um we're working very
hard already as a state to do that um
through the um drug uh evaluation and
classification program but we just don't
have the funding or the ability to get
out there and teach all of these
officers Troopers and deputies that
particular course the other aspect of
that is to increase our Dr program which
is the drug recognition expert program
that will help um correlate all of those
different things together to show that
that individual is actually impaired by
cannabis when they're actually operating
a motor vehicle boat ohrv and so forth
so all of those trainings would need to
come forth and then the bigger piece to
that is our our laboratory uh right now
uh our laboratory is very backed up um
and Melissa could probably speak to that
far better than I could um but we we
need to help with testing we need need
to help with the facility we need to
help to be able to get those blood tests
that are turned around and the other
piece is the refusal piece that we um
struggle here within New Hampshire um we
have a an exorbitantly high refusal rate
so to be able to have someone that's
convicted of that marijuana or um THC um
crime we need to be able to have um more
tests and more evidence to be able to do
that right now if someone refuses there
is no Dr um evaluation there is no blood
test so to be able to prove that and to
make sure that we are doing it prop L we
need to increase all of those aspects of
that education and our laboratory to do
cost so let just ask some clarifying
questions to make sure we all go on the
same so when you're talking about
refusal you talking refusal of fsts or
refusal of blood draw all of the above
Senator so as soon as you refuse one
thing you refuse as far as the ALS
process goes but as soon as you refuse
anything we basically have no evidence
to be able to prove a a solid um DUI
conviction for a drug rated offense so
I'm trying to remember because I think
the statute changed refusals are is that
just an administrative suspension when
someone refuses or is that
statutorily so so there's it's the
two-prong system right so we have the
administrative side of Health through
the DMV which we talk about 265 A14 with
all the the refusal pieces um so it is
that two-prong system so the best way to
explain to that is is hey that
individual gets arrested for DWI they
are criminally charged but there's also
the administrative side by the dsnv 426
form which is the ALS form that we read
that set of administrative rights to
that individual to have them either take
a test or not take a test and right now
our state is obviously one of the
highest refusal states in the country um
so to be able to have and get that
evidence that we need to prove that
someone is actually under the influence
of um cannabis or THC we need to have um
those tests to be able to prove that
case and make it right for that
particular
individual does that answer your
question it does I I I guess my question
is given how high a refusal raate is
probably outside the scope of this
commission but maybe it's time to review
that statute again and make the penalty
a little higher to to encourage
compliance agreed sir um but we can pick
that up another time on a different
topic um Frank and then Senator Ganon
thank uh just quick questions so how do
you all kind of investigate right now
and then T is it through the Dr program
people who are driving under the
influence of opioids or other
prescription drugs the exact same
process sir so it it's the same thing it
would be roadside field sobriety tests
um there would be determination to um
develop basically probable cause that
that particular individual is under the
influence of whatever substance it may
be they're placed under arrest they're
brought back they're read their
administrative license suspension rights
and then it's up to them whether they
take a test or not take a test thank you
I think there's going to be a
conversation later on about whether or
not we amend 265 to allow a crime of
facial level of Poss in in a blood
sample but we're not there yet send
again submits to a blood test is there a
certain THC level that I'm not aware
that say you're like number
like so there's a lot of talk about that
and there right now here in New
Hampshire there is not and um I can tell
you from the Department of Safety side
of the house we are not asking for that
nor do we think that that is something
that's appropriate nationally there's
nothing siid there are certain states
there are certain states that do have
per se laws for um for THC
um okay thanks so Bill just don't inste
of again just know I'm going to ask the
doctor over there to do some research
for us um to give us a standard that we
potentially use in 265 to establish a
primate faal standard for impairment so
Chief yes just to bring it to a more of
a precise pinpoint here would with
respect to collisions that result in
serious bodily injury and or fatalities
right um often times if the operator uh
suspected operator that caused the
Collision who may be impaired by
cannabis or other drugs is uh um not
able to submit to test uh U due to
injury or other reasons uh but even may
be subject to mandatory blood draw uh we
we still are hampered here in the state
of New Hampshire with respect to gaining
any conviction with respect to
impairment there is no operation you
just arrive at the scene of the
Collision uh and you have injured
operators uh including the one that
caused the Collision uh who may be
impaired so there there should be
whether or not as part of this
discussion with this commission or
elsewhere uh looking at other Provisions
where other states have enacted uh some
Provisions with respect to either blood
uh or other testing uh as the trooper
indicated that uh would provide us with
a better U Better process of gaining
convis because right now I can tell you
and and Trooper may be able to validate
or not that we have a very very steep
challenge uh not only with all DUIs but
particularly with cannabis related uh
DUIs and in the state of New Hampshire
and that is only going to increase and
there is a significant concern amongst
the Chiefs throughout the state with
respect to how uh cannabis legalization
will impact the safety on our
roads you have something else yeah I
just was gonna ask him a couple
questions so sir if if you're driving
down the road and and you see someone
smoking and you smell the smoke do you
really have to do a a blood test to
charge them with smoking and and driving
sir
um Jordan yeah um
Lieutenant correct me if I'm wrong we
going to say
that it's the operation of the vehicle
not the condition of the driver that
first attracts the attention of the um
law enforcement officer you got somebody
that's bouncing between the yellow and
the white line that's an indication that
an individual should be stopped aside
from the the typical certain certain
tail light out Etc yes represented
certainly that would be definitely one
indicator that absolutely but there are
many times when um you different traffic
violations you end up walking up to the
vehicle and there's certain indications
that that person is impaired so it's not
necessarily just the operation of the
vehicle and then follow up on that uh
because of the longterm retention of
cannaboids in the blood system and the
metabolism by the liver how do you know
there wasn't six weeks ago six months
ago that the individual was that's a
Melissa question I can answer some of
that for you um but yes you are correct
there is a longstanding for different
metabolics of cannabis to stay in your
system there's lots of research out
there talking about um how those levels
are all different in all different
individuals I think it's to say
Lieutenant that any given case even a
DUI for alcohol is a cumulative of of of
facts not just a single in a fact
absolutely it's a totality of the
circumstances correct absolutely C so
Frank Frank um and so in in the draft
bill that we have now we have in terms
of where the revenue is going some money
going to for Dr so that you all can have
more expansive opportunities there is
that the kind of thing you'd want to see
then absolutely not only not only the um
the the training the education for um
the officers we're also um where we in
the drug recognition expert program are
also out in our schools out in our
communities um trying to educate not
only um our saus in um when they're
dealing with impaired children or when
um workers from different um uh
different facets of the community are
looking to see hey can we tell if that
particular employee impaired we as the
state police and the drug recognition
expert we go out and assist them to help
show signs and symptomology that those
particular individuals are under the
influence so we need lots of training to
be able to do that to be able to get out
there in the community and not just out
there enforcing it but also educ edating
thank you so do understand Lieutenant
I'm sorry just to I'm sure you want to
be a cheap one anybody um um it's
estimated we we're put about 5% of All
State of the State Revenue in which is
estimated about $1.8 million to go
specifically for training purposes for
law enforcement to be able to we
recognize you're going to have a harder
job and you need you need the tools
necessary to do it so there's 5% of that
Revenue being earmarked for law
enforcement training I think one of the
bigger ones that um we have to consider
two is the lab the lab um is going to
take a lot of funding to make this um to
work properly um and to be able to do
those blood tests and to give them the
resources that we need to do too so
that's probably a commissioner Quinn
question but yeah we'll find out what
that number looks like and again that
may fall underneath the operational as
some operational expenses that we put
before we give you money out so um any
nope we good any other questions on so
um we'll look at 265a again I'm going to
ask the do to do homework and see if she
can find some sort
of okay let's we'll talk about that when
we we get there um anything else under
18 did we finish
it yeah everybody okay with 18 thank you
lieutenant thank you if you want to
stick around we're gonna ask the doctor
I'm gonna have you jump in right now
before because I have to leave in the
next 20 minutes and I'd like to be
involved in this discussion so why don't
we talk about possible changes need up
at 265a the DUI statute um in order to
make enforcement you know more doable
now that we're adding some more
complexity to it okay so I I did a deep
dive here on a couple of facets that we
all you know were were were discussing
at the last meeting and so um I know
that the medical society sent out some
articles I don't know if those just went
to Senator abbis or if they went to the
whole committee this morning um but no
it's not that that was included also but
um but if not I'm happy to provide them
um so you know I think the overall um
tone was that there's really been no
correlation found between the debr of
intoxication or impairment um and the
THC level concentration in the blood um
the other um challenge that we were
talking about is that you know not
having people who uh were inadvertently
um breaking the law even if they were
not driving intoxicated in in in the
situation of chronic users and uh
there's a really good um meta analysis
that essentially goes over all of the
data that um was available you know two
years ago that showed that even people
who were observed to abstain for over a
day um there are still people who would
test positive at greater than 22 hours
and these are people who you know were
observed smoking admitted to the
hospital for one reason or another they
know they have abstained testing blood
levels at certain times um and were
still above even the um five nanograms
per microl ler um so I think that
there's certainly some challenges there
of of capturing um some some people uh
who are not um intoxicated um or altered
um that would still test positive um the
other um thing that I think speaks to
this was a sort of correlation between
oral fluid and blood uh THC
concentrations um which overall was poor
but it it in this particular article did
discuss that oral fluid THC did appear
to have some utility for investigating
high-risk drivers who have already come
to the police attention for evidence of
impairment um as as as um the police uh
officer just was discussing with us so
not it's a lot of false positives um if
you were just testing everyone um but if
you're testing someone who has at high
risk driving because they appear
impaired um that that was a useful uh
tool
um Chief and
then yes thank you and and uh I
certainly agree with uh the results of
those studies when when we've looked at
other studies uh there was a fairly
Landmark study I don't know if the good
doctor was able to find this out of Ohio
that looked at the uh ability for
operators uh in um with respect to the
decision- making uh and impairment
actions um uh under a test environment
after they have
consumed uh and then there is some
significant lapse in Period of time uh
involving people that are chronic heavy
cannabis use disorder uh patients and
showed significant driving impairment
even days after the the issue here
really goes to whether or not the state
wants to look at ways of making uh uh
cannabis
DUI uh conviction within the realm of
possibility um uh in a legal way uh the
states that have looked at
limits probably the most appropriate way
to look at it is not in a per se limit
but in a prima fascia case which simply
says that whatever limit that's
arbitrarily opposed and again it's an
arbitrary limit clearly those state
legislator have indicated that that it
simply
is uh a matter that can be
considered by the judge in determining
impairment much like the results of
observation and the results of Dr
testing uh it's only a prima fascia
element in the overall
determination so there is a subtle
Nuance there that perhaps
um not for not perhaps Germain for this
particular commission but a
recommendation that a study look at
study commission look at whether or not
265a should be uh amended to include uh
some provision uh that would result in
some premma fascia changes that would uh
enhance the ability for law enforcement
safe so again the question goes down to
we have the 0.08 limit in alcohol the
.16 limit for aggravated um in our and
understanding that a totality of the
circumstances as the lieutenant said
right it's all things you can just pull
somebody over and draw their blood find
out they're point you know they're five
NG per milliliter um nanogram per Mill
and ARR them for impairment you know you
have to have other facts associated with
that stop right there has to be prob
there has to be first Reasonable
Suspicion for the Stop and then you have
to develop a probable cause for the
arrest before you even get to the blood
or brealy right so it's a totality of
fact situation but the question is just
like we've established a standard for
alcohol is there a standard we could put
in the 128 in the 265a statute that
would make it easier for law enforcement
be able to to effectively prosecute
cases of impairment due to marijuana
consumption that's the question not in
connection with a Hardline limit like 08
is um and I think that's where the
science uh is right now because the
science is clear that there is no
scientific per se limit that says a
person at x amount of THC in their
bloodstream is impaired uh so uh given
that their alternative would be to
Simply indicate that a limit uh or a
amount above a particular limit presents
a prima fascia indication not a actual
indication of
impairment and and that's that's perhaps
um the correct way to look at that's
what some other states have done not all
there are states that are per se that
have drawn the same limit just like 008
and that's what it is and there's other
states that simply look at this as a
another element uh in terms of
establishing a pre pran fascia case um
that still needs to be proved up for
impairment so you you can get even in
alcohol right you can get convicted of
DUI and be under an o08 right it's about
your driving right it's about the impair
itself so Prime theoh is is kind of the
nail in the coffin so to speak um but
the but you can have somebody who blows
an ' 06 if I could still prove
impairment due to the consumption of
alcohol I don't have to prove the o08
o08 just makes it easier for me to get
the conviction but I can proove you can
prove it under an 08 so again even if we
set a standard it doesn't mean that that
standard is um an absolute conviction it
just means that you would need
additional facts to establish uh Pro
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt a person was
operating a vehicle Under the Influence
that was caused by either marijuana or
alcohol that would be correct that would
be a you're discussing what I'm
case sorry I think we agree very much
with you Senator that mean I think the
science is pretty clear there is no
number there's no magic number and so if
we're trying to put something in there
that's just going to be arbitrary um
just because that's where the science
currently is and so if if we invest in
Dr if we give the Troopers and other law
enforcement folks the tools they need to
figure out you know to have the
resources to do that totality analysis
and then to bring that for prosecution I
think that would be the way the best way
safe Jordan and then
10 yes and you're talking about the
totality of the circumstances an
alcoholic of course can operate a motor
vehicle way over the
008 um
limit successfully merely because of the
body's adaptation to the alcohol level
therein um there's a functional I think
there's the phrase
functional Behavior some of any IM
material the same thing applies to the
utilization of uh cannaboids or
inhalation of uh
cannaboids however I would hate to
see some individual who had went to a
party three weeks ago be hit up with a
prime facia case because he was paying
in attention because he was drinking
while driving but the drinking was
coffee and he spilled his coffee and
went over the yellow line
and something we have to take consider
understood again that goes back to the
totality of circumstances right so again
when you get in the court if he is
covered in coffee and and the officer
says yeah well he was covering cofy when
I pulled him over and I said he spilled
it but I I could I I asked him anyway
you're going to lose your case right so
the judge is going to throw it out so
again it has you have to be able to
prove impairment the impairment is
caused by the consumption of alcohol or
marijuana thank you Mr chair actually I
just wanted to say that the the best way
to protect our streets is to not
legalize weed in the first place and and
I'm really I'm really glad to hear my
colleague say that you know he's
mentioning someone going to a party and
getting and and and then maybe getting
tested weeks later isn't that true for
isn't that why we should not even
remotely allow public smoking cuz then
we we could be hit up for an oui or a
smoking all Mr chairman chief mikica
first and then we'll come over here I
mean commissioner M okay Mr chairman I
would just ask that the chief be allowed
to come back he has the answer of the
original question okay thank
you
thank you chairman mik thank you Senator
chairman um thank you for the two
minutes it looked very familiar to me
when I saw it I mentioned to Chairman
mik when I walked away um this is the
same verbage that we have in title 13 um
as I researched it it looks like it's uh
under 179 uh one second we're going back
to number 17
I think you're you're going back to we
were talking about enforcement activity
and verifying non
compliance yeah page
237 so just so everyone knows what we're
talking about because we kind of jump
subjects good I'm sorry good no my fault
sir um so uh on the C on the uh title 13
side of the house um we're looking at
that in 179 colon 5 uh dasb which is
enforcement activity verifying
non-compliance you're absolutely right
in the direction that you were going in
Senator um what uh the legislature did
um uh some time ago is separate these
two entities so an
investigation that has non-compliance in
it is a misdemeanor but if we are
actively going out with uh an underage
buyer uh to do compliance checks it's a
violation so they they have separated
those two it it was straight across the
board uh Miss meanor now it's a
violation for that and then they would
jump into internally under rule our
Progressive accountability starting with
education working their way up through
okay so I I think what you talked about
is again one is an an enforcement action
second one is there's a car accident
alcohol in the car miners involved
receipt from a local store they follow
it up find out that the store sold the
minor liquor that would be a misdemeanor
level of ense whereas your um
enforcement activity would be considered
a violation level off absolutely spot
on thank you Chief thank you all right
back to our 265a conversation have a
question oh yeah good yes I have a
question of Dr youngren um I think I
heard you say that there's no
correlation with impairment and THC
levels in the blood is that correct
correct I'm happy in so the degree of
intoxication
theing that for do not throw canvas at
all then it could
be1 and I could be intoxicated where if
you're a chronic user um you know some
of this data is showing that after 24
hours from smoking some people still had
13 nanograms from
care okay um I'm just trying to
comprehend this because I I think we
heard testimony from a child
psychologist a psychiatrists from Boston
Children's and and a
neuroscientist that are relating uh THC
levels with tri the triggering of
psychosis so if we C if we have science
behind that I'm just wondering what the
measurements I mean what what can we do
to be able to pinpoint this yeah I think
I I I'm certainly not an expert on that
but I would say it's really I mean
clearly the literature shows it's really
challenging that there's the need to
enforce the law and make sure that our
you know children are safe the there's
Public Safety for driving but that
depending on if you're a naive user or a
chronic user the level of which your THC
would be in the blood to show
intoxication would be extremely
different and so you know even Below in
theory below the point 2 level for an or
the I'm sorry the two nanograms per
milliliter you may be intoxicated if
you've never used before but at the much
higher level you may not if you're a
chronic user yes I understand that
tolerance um I'm just I'm just trying to
wrap my brain around um in the news just
uh this week the the state trooper that
was killed by uh the and the um the
driver of the truck plad guilty his uh
blood levels were 224 with with cannabis
uh THC impairment so I'm just curious so
we we don't have any cut off I I
understand that between the point 0.008
with alcohol but a0 224 sounds pretty
serious to me and and a life was lost as
a result of that so how are we why are
we considering
legalizing um you know Mar marijuana
cannabis whatever you call it when we
don't have the in the measurements um
for uh intoxication and and impairment I
mean I think that's a very different
conversation than the one we're having
today I understand your concerned for
sure um I I don't know what a point 22
is I think all of the literature that
yeah I don't even know what that I mean
that's you know all of the things that
I've seen in terms of you know even from
the you know accident analysis and
prevent prevention journals like
everything is uh is two is nanograms per
milliliter and that's that's a whole
digit so I I mean I can't really say you
know anything if you told me it was like
150 nanograms per millit like probably
any person would be intoxicated with
that um but the a two versus a five
versus a 15 I I think it's really it's
really hard
toit what I recommend is everybody can
go home and do a little bit of research
you know just simply I'm looking at the
National Institute of Health has one and
they have one clear statement in it say
furthermore drivers with a blood THC
concentration of three milligram three
nanograms per milliliter had an
increased risk for being judged impaired
as compared to drivers with lower
concentrations so that seemed to be the
break point of if you below this more
likely you're not going to be found
impaired but if you're above this you
are going to be found impaired so and
that's the National Institute of Health
statement on 30,000 with 30,000 U
participants in the study what you're
saying contradicts what doctor just said
because there that that is there is a
correlation with impairment so but I
think but I also to representative or's
Point yeah right High consumers are
going to have a natural level that may
not relate correlate directly to
impairment right because they they
consume on a more regular basis right so
Mr chair
yes our current um our current laws
regarding driving while intoxicated
include prescription
drugs and again the uh the level of uh I
there's a board that talks about uh the
ability of a person to have
drugs within their system and still
function I can't remember what it is
right now uh applies you can have a
person on valum driving into a telephone
pole they're driving while
intoxicated and it could be a very small
amount of valum because that's the first
time they take it or it could be a very
large amount of valum because they're
tolerant of that so the the the
phraseology of a prim officiate case
depends upon the individual and we go
back to the totality and that needs to
be included so if you want to look it up
I guess I recommend you go do the
research like I said I I just did a
quick quick search and I found Institute
of Health's statement they they have
kind of this is the Tipping Point level
right I don't know what that means for
our statute but there that's what they
have as a there as a Tipping Point level
for impairment um with that I am Frank
go ahead U Mr CH yeah I think also if
it's helpful so the triaa um Foundation
of for Traffic Safety also did a report
and they found quote there's no
correlation or no concentration of th
that allows us to reli reliably predict
that someone is impaired behind the
wheel um in a way that we can with
alcohol so just additional information
helpful right so here's scoop I have to
leave I'm going to Florida um I have a
tax policy to go to so uh Senator
Whitley is going to take over the rest
of the meeting um we are at um
enforcement of contracts did I actually
use my copy and keep notes on here got
it actually I do want to just have one
comment so I'm not going to be here for
it when you're talking about F20 um the
next one I want you to consider there's
some concerns I have have around
licensed
occupations um in this state and this is
trying to do non-discriminatory language
for licensed occupations and I think we
have to be careful because we have some
federal requirements and federal
guidelines we get stuck around you think
about a CDL license and a CDL truck
driver who gets popped for a who does a
random drug testing gets popped for
cannabis being in their system and gets
fired but according to this they
couldn't get
fired and so we have some concerns you
got have to we have to go through in 20
to talk about occupations and
occupational licensing nurses um you
know there's another one police officers
right these are some licenses and
certifications we issue where we may
want to say there's a zero tolerance in
that but this language as I read 20 um
doesn't allow for that it says you can't
discriminate against anybody Who's
acting in doing a a legal activity on
that on that issue we actually might
want opl the lawyer from oplc to to come
in so don't you think yeah that's fine
if you want to put it off and we can
invite uh Lindsay and and group in I
will do you want to have Dy do that for
the next one but just I have some
concerns around that myself on on Li
licensed occupations so and with that
the share's yours thank you very much
and Daryl should be here he should take
a break somewhere between 12 and 12:15
Daryl will be here or sen abis will be
here around 1 o'clock and he'll take
over the chair okay thank you
guys the travels
yay
taxes um I I I would say that we should
hold that issue of opl not hold it we'll
we'll we'll get we'll get to it and I
think we should have the lawyer from
oplc talk so now we are on page
24 section 19 enforcement of contracts
that seeing none oh uh Senator Lang did
you want to leave your copy with
me you keep it updated that's going to
try the deadline
yeah you just give it the daily he can
we done just if we if it's approved just
check it off if there's changes just
whatever they
okay okay seeing none on 19 moving on to
section 20 non-discrimination for state
legal cannabis activities and prior
convictions I think will hold on the
license conversation and daily will uh
reach out to the lawyer I'm sorry the
executive director of oplc Lindsey
Courtney and maybe um have her come in
and discuss this further with us but are
there any other comments on Section 20
starting on line
26 just one comment Senator uh from the
law enforcement
perspective uh it it it throws this
section is is so broad that uh with
respect to certification
and Licensing of police officers in the
state of New Hampshire they would be in
direct conflict with federal law with
respect to Firearms right um also CDLs
as the good Senator mentioned and N but
certainly here with respect to our
certification process in New Hampshire
with respect to law enforcement officers
uh that that has to be rectified right I
think this section needs a lot of
work I'm wondering actually if the
Attorney General's office wants to work
with PLC on this section I think it
needs a lot of work because there
there's a lot of interaction with state
and federal law or would you be willing
to do
that I can I can note that and take a
look at that okay thank
you yeah yeah I just wanted to add you
know that there's I'm carrying a couple
licenses right here you know license to
transport refrigeration and Ed
Refrigeration you know those are those
are federally governed yep and uh you
definitely can't be smoking weed or
using drugs while doing those things
right there are yeah there are lots of
other require I think this the section
is
complicated any other comments so I
think we're going to put a pin on
um I and we'll have the AG and the oplc
work with that same with
two moving on to 25
section
three seeing none moving on to section
to no I guess it's okay because it's
only talk about entitlement or conduct
to uh maybe perhaps have a conversation
with the director of DCF on this issue
to make sure we are not um in any way
statute Madam chair yes if you're going
to use the word unreasonable danger you
have to um Define it what's
unreasonable right and I and I think to
that point
uh we need to have DCA offway on
this
okay section
employment
yes yes um if you have somebody that has
that is using and um it's you they're
going to work with children right are we
then putting them you know the children
and the uh employer in um Ham's Way by
with this
chapter discriminate in the hiring
termination or anything right so I think
we're I think
I think there's a lot of um issues with
this section because I I don't want to
interfere with existing law and so I I
want to
actually touch base with the Attorney
General's office on this issue and I
think if you can come back to us with
potentially some language because I feel
like some of this may be unnecessary
because of existing law um and I think
we need to clean this up a lot actually
because because employment there there
you know there's a whole body of law
around employment law and there's a
whole body of law around child
protection and I feel like this is
agree yes this appears to touch large
bodies of law
Ed um I think I think we we need to come
like employee Child Protection you know
employment
I I think the issue of
non-discrimination is certainly
important important but we don't want to
interfere with existing
law and you're referring to things like
um um some financial institutions
require drug testing Etc exactly and and
like you know there with employment law
we already have existing state statutes
and common law I mean you know we need
to make sure that's consistent in this
and I don't you know I I'm not even sure
reference yeah thank you Senator I think
the distinction should be between uh
professional licensure and
non-discrimination and that uh I think
that's where some of the work that the
AG and oplc needs to Y needs to work
there I think that this whole section
probably needs to be subject to further
review I agree great just want to flag
on Section seven sorry on line 37 it it
clarifies that um it does not impact the
ability of employee employers to
discipline for engage in Canabis use
while but also there's in the
subsections there talks about um uh
conflicts with federal law or any other
um uring that there's no conflict of
laws
there
y sureair yes uh a good phrase in in
this section might be notwithstanding
other Pro uh provisions of other laws
exactly yep okay so we're going to come
back to that we'll defer to the Attorney
General's office because there's
multiple bodies of law that we are
engaging with in the in these sections
on to page
thoughts I I think that there's a little
challenge here put I mean again I am I'm
not a transplant surgeon by any means
but um and not so much around the use of
the illicit substance but smoking I know
that for certain organ transplants like
a lung transplant you have to be
abstinent from smoking for a certain
amount of time just like you would for a
liver transplant with alcohol so I
I think that that's a little tricky it's
um because it's not necessarily the act
of the using the elicit substance as
much as the root of uh uh in which
you're taking it so
um I think that that might be sticky for
lung
transplant uh would the medical society
like to come back to us with a
recommendation on that yeah Frank I I so
we were part of the Coalition I think
this was from 639 um so I think we had
tried so I definitely understand if
there's changes that need to be made but
uh it's like the definition of a listed
substance it's trying to limit and then
make sure that any decisions y all make
it's just based on evidence-based
criteria not just because someone
happens to smoke marijuana yeah no
definitely and I don't think that it
would anyway I think Mor say saying like
if smoking smoking sa is a criteria for
transplant
that
um so you'll come back to us with a
recommendation on that okay moving on to
line 13 notwithstanding any other
provisional law unless there is a
specific finding that the individual's
use cultivation or possession of
cannabis could create a danger to the
individual or another person it shall be
a violation of conditions of parole
probation or pre-trial release to engage
in contact uh conduct Allowed by this
chapter or test positive for cannabis
Etc
comments Senator Lang had a question
about whether cultivation should be
this I mean I think our thought is that
if people are engaged in employment this
is all lawful cultivation under this
chapter and so they should be able to do
that unless there is some individualized
basis that that there that they
okay all right moving
on uh data collection so we are page 26
line 31 data collection related to
cannabis legalization and regulation
again this is language that came from HB
639 I think um in this conversation the
uh data collection has been a very
important topic I think AC in the
legislature r large um yes so um I I was
just uh wanted to suggest that just
throughout the the um a piece of
legislation here that we're using
substance use disorder instead of
substance abuse or misuse just to be
consistent with the current medical
nomenclature and you know removing
stigma um from the language so I mean I
I'm happy to go through the document
there's a lot of times where it says
substance abuse but um so substance use
disorder substance use disorder
treatment prevention throughout the
document if we can use substance use
disorder in place of substance
flag
okay data collection any comments on the
on the data collection
Provisions in here yeah just a comment
and that um that's going to be um um a
cost factor for the agencies engage
whether it's dep Department of Safety or
others so um I'm not sure uh how to
reflect that appropriately but
uh uh there should be a revenue stream
that should
support uh data collection and Reporting
otherwise it it could be very costly
yeah so as Senator Lang mentioned 5% of
revenues will be going to law
enforcement for all you know for
statute mam chair yes should we include
the cross in there that says uh non
identifiable
data non-personally
identifi
yep
individual I think there's language
already in law regarding that just use
you know OS has it
handy
okay
collection okay moving on to page 27 the
Cannabis
fund okay so la uh section one actually
fund
yes so this is the section that I
referred to at the beginning where it's
kept separate and distinct just so this
doesn't interrupt the current banking
relationship the state has in the event
that that bank doesn't want to engage
and take and uh banking marijuana
related businesses y um so that's just
to protect that relationship okay and
did you have language I'm sorry that you
wanted the language is already in it's
already in there y great thank
you
okay section
two shall include the cost of admin
Administration section three to the
Liquor
Commission any
comments
okay section
[Music]
four substance use prevention and
Recovery
Fund yeah uh so I I think that it may be
helpful to have some clarity about who
is um who's framing the public education
campaign you know if there was something
um in the language about you know either
having some medical expertise or
involving of DHHS or public you know
Public Safety um I think that would be
helpful yeah and actually to that issue
um we have in our uh Memo from new
Futures they had some proposal for that
microphone just make sure you're
record thank you again for the record
Kate fry vice president of advocacy at
new Futures so uh this just section
needs to be just cleaned up a little bit
but to to be consistent with what we
discussed already regarding the creation
of the
substance um Abuse Prevention treatment
and Recovery Fund I'm certainly um fine
with language substance use um disorder
uh we've established that fund however
when we go through the Appropriations in
this section I think um if you look at
uh page two of what we sent you um
number
six um page uh we talk about the
Cannabis control fund the dispersement
of funds they're sending that funding to
the
department I think that was in an
earlier draft um where it really should
be going to um the substance abuse
prevention and Recovery Fund consistent
with the language we discussed earlier
um I put 10% in I know that percent
might change just because that was one
of the numbers that was offered and then
to the doctor's point I would agree that
um although there's an
appropriation um it doesn't NE for a
500,000 for a campaign it doesn't
necessarily direct anyone to do the
campaign right so it is missing language
to direct the department to do that
campaign and that's in um under number
nine in our document on page three
there's language that um addresses that
does everyone have this Memo from new
language so so we're looking at new
Futures memo number nine where they make
a
recommendation about the direction of
the appropriation and I think that makes
a lot of sense
do that address your concern yes
okay good and then under num number six
it just clarifies that the funds aren't
going to the department directly they're
going to the Substance Abuse Prevention
and Recovery Fund so just I think it
combined two or three different bills so
you that makes a lot of sense to
you
actually I'm sorry Kate will you come
topic so after your
discussion uh in number 10 you recommend
new Futures recommended the addition of
new language to create adjustment uh a
Justice reinvestment fund to support
communities individuals can you discuss
that yes thank you for uh bringing that
up and reminding me of this piece so
this was um originally in a draft of the
bill uh of HB 639 it never made it to
print um but this was something that I
thought had a lot of support with um the
uh proide people who cared about social
justice we one of our principles is
around social justice and uh what we
have learned lessons from other states
um and so one of the recommendations was
to create a Justice reinvestment fund to
do um look at the issues um below we
know a lot of times when we talk about
commercializing addictive products what
ends up happening is we end up
revictimized the people who have been
impacted by the war of on drugs so this
was at one point a big um selling point
for even the pro side I think uh the
Coalition that had been working
um on the bill had at one point
supported it but uh it seems to kind of
Fallen by the wayside I know the ACLU
well I will I will say from my
perspective I think this is incredibly
important piece you know one of the
reasons why individuals and and in fact
constituents and the community at large
is uh in so in support of legalization
is because the disproportion
impact of prohibition on communities of
color and um and those uh within the
substance use community and so I feel
like this is an important part of the
conversation and I think without it we
sort of have a
lopsided approach in New Hampshire I
think if we're going to be a leader in
New Hampshire um on taking a public
health perspective I think it doesn't
make sense not to have something like
this I'm open to other comments as well
yep
um no as Kate said this is something
that we have pursued and we think is
really important so we would very much
support the inclusion of this language
commission anyone
else an agreeable Bunch
today everyone's
Kate I don't know do we have any house
members left nope I don't know if that
was an issue in the house that was dis
oh representative with with this Justice
reinvestment fund I didn't
know that that language actually never
made it to the Senate so we didn't have
a conversation I didn't know what the
conversation was in the house if there
even was
one on this this Justice reinvestment
fund okay okay Al will that when it
comes to these specific
funds representative all to have a
imagine that's
right Senator Whitley yes um on that on
that issue it never actually made it to
the house for consideration in an
earlier draft by the time it came out of
os was I removed so yeah the house is
not considered okay thank thank you for
that background again I do think it's an
important uh part of the puzzle here and
we do have the time now to um make sure
we have a balanced approach so I
appreciate uh the consensus on that
issue okay moving on um section
five uh we have an appropriation
particularly the department of safety I
don't know if the department of safety
wanted to comment on that we're on line
okay so with the would the department of
safety just get back to us if they have
okay okay
um moving on of the remaining funds 50%
of the remaining funds shall be uh
fund
system and then uh maybe we'll have a
convers a further conversation on three
subsection three line 13 on
I didn't know if the public health folks
had further suggestions
or I have a um question I think of
um Chief Miker on on the uh 10% of
remaining fins or 25 million whichever
is less shall be credited to the
Substance Abuse Prevention and Recovery
Fund how does that um 25 million uh
compared to the allocation which is
currently dedicated through the alcohol
fund the the the
profits it's 5% of the profit so the
alcohol fund was 5% or around 11 million
last year 11 million approxim
approximately okay so it Madam chair is
is there a provision here that that
prevents the direction of these funds to
the general fund as what happened with
the uh tobacco
settlement Kate you're welcome to come
back that's an important point because
you know it has historically been rated
every single year um and I know that's
through so again for the record Kate fry
from um new Futures yes so in um again
in our memo I believe um on number two
the creation of that fund the Substance
Abuse Prevention and treatment fund we
had discussed this quite a bit is that
the idea behind that was to create a
separate fund following the opiate
baitman trust fund um that was
completely separate from the general
fund couldn't be touched um funds
couldn't be swept because what had
previously happened with the alcohol
fund is that was more of a budget
process though that um RSA was suspended
every two years in the in the early year
so that's why you weren't seeing the
full 5% this makes this is a completely
separate fund you can't trust or that
you can trust that does not get diverted
um and again learning from the opiate
abatement the creation of the opiate
abatement trust fund where these um
settlement funds are coming in we want
to make sure we wanted to make sure
those weren't going elsewhere so we just
copied that language to do the same
thing here okay thank you yeah and and
um as new Futures noted in their memo
the commission was had reached consensus
on inclusion of that and made a lot of
sense thank you for raing that yes the
commission has oversight on that yes
thank you for that point Senator Lang oh
don't go away yet Senator Lang had made
the recommendation in subsection three
or an issue of discussion about
conversation regarding funding the
three or if you have any comments about
that under the Cannabis fund establish
Roman numeral 3 or um subsection 3 on
um so I think there's a couple thoughts
here uh so we've heard very clearly over
and over again that there's a
significant um connection that has been
established by science with um
specifically High potency products and
uh mental health issues certainly with
psychosis um so I think with whatever
number you end up what there you could
go around this a couple ways you could
have the governor's uh the Substance
Abuse Prevention and treatment fund
which is overseen by the governor's
commission
um that aside a certain amount to go
towards that specific issues I think um
the concern is that the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
just does funding for substance use
disorder which is not necessarily the
case they do prevention treatment and
Recovery uh funding for behavioral
health issues so they have done
significant amount of funding for the
behavioral health issues co-occurring
issues um but if the concern is about
significantly earmarking um an amount to
go towards um a an issue that Nami is uh
concerned about significantly I think
they're concerned about firsttime
psychosis and having cbha support
supports at the cbha you could set aside
a certain amount of that from the um
from that amount that goes to the
governor's commission but there's also
something here in Roman numeral 5 right
that you could clarify that um goes to
um clarify that might um address those
issues more so I do think there are
places within here that we could um come
up with some language that addresses
those concerns
specifically um and either have it um a
part of the funding that goes to the
governor's commission or tweak five or
um you know if they wanted to set aside
a different amount we're certainly
amendable to
that goad I'm I think there's a risk in
setting aside um dollars for advocacy
organizations when funds are are in
scarce uh demand in the state if that if
if I'm understanding what I'm hearing
right here uh well I I think especially
if it child well you're right so with I
think the uh thought about Nami is their
their more provider side of their shop
that works on the first EP psychosis
issue so actually Kate what I'm going to
ask of you is to
um go ahead so I actually have another
suggestion I just had to find it so on
page two of the bill under the Substance
Abuse Prevention and Recovery
funds under Roman numeral 5 y this is it
gets much more specific of how these
funds are to be spent and you will see
already that there is some language for
mental health TR uh treatment with a
focus on Dual diagnosis of both mental
health and substance misuse disorders um
I don't know if that's to the extent
that they're looking into but we could
tweak that language there
um so you know there's there's some
wiggle room here that we could put some
language in I I would want to just look
at what they're interested in funding
again the Lang the the funding wouldn't
go directly I don't think to Nami I
think the intent is to have an
infrastructure that can deal with these
um in uh increasing cases of psychosis
and mental health is correct and I think
that you're right that we're not going
to name the organization in the statute
yeah so if if there's some language I'm
happy to to try to uh work that in
somewhere I just haven't seen anything
directly from Namy all right if you
wanted to touch base with them and make
sure that that issue is covered then you
can come back to us on that okay thank
you thank
you Senator if we're done with that
section before Kate gets up oh sorry
Kate um it's your
day I I believe I may be incorrect but I
think last time we didn't get to this
issue it's on page three um number eight
in new Futures memo oh page three of the
memo say that again page three number
eight uh which is the public health
advisory committee that's doing with the
public health side but not the business
side I think that we did I my memory
because I have a check next to it okay
is that we reached consensus I just
don't know if we figured out where
exactly that was going yes I I was
remiss I I was gonna um make some
suggestions I'm happy to work with um
the commissioner and um Le uh Mr VAR to
to provide some suggestions of where
that public health advisory commission
might fit in I was thinking around the
section around R making but we can
certainly talk about that and I've since
had some thoughts and some suggestions
since we discussed the commissioner and
I I want to be clear that it's not to
approve every single product it's more
to establish guidelines on public health
um related issues we need to be
concerned about with some products right
so we have a consensus that it should be
included I think the question is where
it should go you agree okay anything
else from Kate before she gets
up thank you we were losing people
rapidly yeah I don't you know I think
Senator well Senator abbis is going to
be here can I just take a pause and ask
what people's schedules are for the
remainder of the day it doesn't make
sense to me to keep doing this if we
don't have a critical mass
here you're here for the
duration yeah I I think they mentioned 3
p.m. right
and yeah no right I just I wanted
because some people have to leave it
looks like it is you made great progress
so yeah well I I think at some point
we're gonna pause for lunch and then
come back at 1 are people or is that
good for everyone okay just ask a
question is this the intent to uh
complete the line in line out today or
is that is that going to continue on on
depends we get okay yeah all right so
it's 12:15 I think this is a good
stopping point why don't we come back at
1:00 and um hopefully Senator AAL will
join us but I think we we're making good
you
glad thank you and
I'll reconvene from the recess sorry
that I was
late
by that time I was three hours and 15
minutes late thank you Senate again
you're
welcome we're on page 29 if I understand
that correctly yeah we made good
progress Senator with um going through
the various funds I think we have some
open questions just for your information
if you if you go back to page 24
starting on line 26 these are all the
nisp discrimination Provisions I think
we the commission rightly identified
that this needs a whole lot of work
because there's a whole body of existing
Law related to licenses relating to
employment and so the Attorney General's
office has graciously offered to um work
on this with us to make sure that we're
not interfering with other uh bodies of
law so um and that brings us to right up
to page 29 to the statutory
changes
are we on number eight yeah we hadn't we
yeah so and this has to do with
penalties I I guess this would apply to
the black market when I what I read the
section mean we have any anyone have any
comments on you know parag uh paragraphs
maybe we should double whatever the
penalties are for the black market just
double
them so
that I understand what you're saying and
I understand the logic behind that the
problem is is it's it's it's a certain
class of each drug is put into classes
usually not a
standalone um we probably want to make
it consistent with the bootlegging laws
but if we do did something like that but
I know that's not really rampid
um I know there'll be a black market
impact one way or another many say it
the black market will increase if we do
this but I
penalties is the I guess is the current
penalty in insufficient does anyone find
to
me well is the current penalty stopping
the black market I would say no then
well unlike unlike our model I I mean
unlike the other states who did nothing
to deal with the black market they just
they say there's a black market problem
they just sit there and do nothing about
it they just make an observation and
carry around with the day I think what
we have here is a model that's designed
to actually be remain competitive with
the black market so the price point will
actually be closer in the number as
opposed to it which disincentivizes
someone from buying something on the
street which you don't want um it's the
idea is for them to come to a store here
one of the retail stores so we're hoping
that that would actually be we have a
competitive price point rather than like
Massachusetts it's almost double the
price when you count the sales tax so
people have lower incomes are still
going to resort to the black market
we're trying to move away from that not
oversaturate the legal market and that's
why having a hand on the wheel is a good
idea so I understand the other states
had that problem we're trying to avoid
that
problem they're like a moop flying into
a light the way the states we're not
doing that so maybe I would say we let's
see how it plays out in the real world
and I'm with you if it gets if it gets
start to get out of hand I would be I
now um right yeah no I agree with you
Senator and I think just clarifying as
well that we're we're not talking about
changing anything we're just really
pulling people who are 21 and over out
of the current marijuana penalty regime
because we're legalizing into substance
and so this is really just how does it
impact people 20 under
21 right so I think that's important
context for what these statutory changes
are we're not changing any law we're
just m uh we're not changing any policy
really uh we are just updating current
law to reflect what we're doing
policy-wise in the remainder of the
statute the remainder of the bill and
and not to get too far into this on
right now but if we whatever we decide
on a possession limit of what you can
purchase I thought that the the law
should remain
consistent with this and this is three
this is 34 of an ounce or more I don't
think we need to address it right now
but in future legislation we may want to
line everything up y we'd very much
agree with
12 it says marijuana does that need I
know we want to use is marijan and
cannabis is used interchangeably the law
at this point I know cannabis is the
term people want but that's the correct
term well what in in existing law 318 it
yeah
someone can help me I'm drawing a blank
what was the rational for striking
paragraph B from the
it does it seem like they were uh
assuming it's going to be legal so
they're just striking that right because
those things are now going to be legal
over 20
minut
okay the the attorney can the offer any
insight on that in the AG's
office are you speaking to line 15b 15
to
20 this has to do with I my
understanding if they qualified for
through with if they had a therapeutic C
but were under 21 they wouldn't be
prosecuted I guess what would happen if
you're
20 because this has to do with personal
we you don't want to then stop
Prosecuting people for having the
therapy utic
card or a 20-year-old with therapeutic
Mike not sure if it would cover that I'm
just
um trying to interpret that don't have
don't have a good answer for you at the
moment we'll come back to that but just
maybe for everyone's um brain we don't
want to inadvertently allow criminalize
the therapeutic 20-year-old with a
therapeutic card number one but we also
don't want to have no penalty in the law
at all for someone who's 20 just using
right I have a question I'm trying to
interpret the um it it looks like
marijuana includes the leaves stems
flowers and seeds of all species of the
plant genus um cannabis but shall not
include the resin extracted from any
part of such plant why is that I mean we
concentrates are such a problem today oh
that's current law I'm sorry where you
reading from so I think you're looking
at page 30 line8 that's current
law but current law seems like it needs
needs to be um amended
because that that's the resin and the
concentrates are a major problem today
shouldn't we strike seeds as well I mean
is that it just doesn't seem
right anyone I'm reading this
correctly
so we Define on page three cannabis and
so I don't know if we just want to
reference because this is the problem
like it's already in the code it's a
problem or sometimes we say cannabis
sometimes we say marijuana so if we just
want to we have the definition
and all parts of the plant okay we gr it
on okay so it seems like it's contrary
to the definition on page three it's
it's in inclusive of all parts of the
on so maybe uh if I may maybe we just
need to um they need to right so just
remove this de definition and instead
use our new definition for cannabis on
page three of the legislation I think
that's a good idea
yeah does that make sense yeah all right
so on page just I'll repeat it just to
make sure on page 30 lines five sorry
lines 8 through 14 we would strike that
section and and basically by reference
we now need to reference the new
section or
you any any other comments on this
section and maybe next next hearing if
we can get some confirmation that would
look at section
B
I don't I don't think we really need to
address this anymore this is the
existing law and this is the for some
under 21 this has to do with the three
quarters announce Vision I don't think
either
um Chief any comment on on number on
yes yeah page 31 line 31
yeah
is this the section regarding possessed
by a person who's under 21 years of age
or in the case of in an amount
exceeding The Possession limit defined
by
318 DF col one is that what you're
referring to yeah so we be so alcohol or
drug impairment possession of
31 so again this is the existing law so
all we're doing doing in terms of
changing it is getting rid of that last
sentence online 37 38 but um
I I think because aren't we
striking I think that our part might be
stricken so we got to make sure here you
mean
yeah
Senator would we have to specify here
that it'd be driving with possession
while you know um outside of the
parameters of this new code section
something like that because we're
striking basically most of the stuff
under 318-b two right so that they're
going to go there and basically be a
repeal so we got to put that the same
consistency you just brought up needs to
be brought here yep so there's a cleanup
yes
okay
no this is the new section are we on to
section 15 yes this is the new section
section
well everyone's good with this section
yeah Mr chair um if we're on the
analment section uh perhaps the Attorney
General's office weigh in on the
question
with respect to subparagraph
B as to whether or not dismissal of
marijuana charge would
imperil uh
other contemporaneous charges that uh
were associated with an underlying
marijuana charge is now
dismissed particularly if it's still in
process so for example marijuana stop
results in the disclosure or the
discovery of let's say a murder weapon
it sounds like the way it's written that
someone that there's a pending
prosecution that this would
essentially say that they have to stop
that in mid prosecution because the
behavior that they were being prosecuted
for is no longer a crime right which
although that makes
sense certainly makes logical
sense I
mean we don't normally give it a
retroactive application like that I mean
it's
still I think they'll likely be able to
get the conviction nulled and they would
be prosecutory discretion but do we
prosecution my opinion would be yes
because it I it's a fundamental Fair
fairness issue why continue a
prosecution that's something that's not
legal anymore or not illegal anymore I'm
with you I think that the discretion is
is pretty obvious but I guess
legislating to mandate is the question
yeah and I think it's necessary
because even if you're you can seek an
analment afterwards you still have to go
proceeding but this is the existing law
anyway right no this is a new section oh
yeah
I mean I think this is the middle ground
because you know what I would prefer is
all prior convictions of marijuana be
eliminated we have a lot of folks in
jail because of marijuana and you know
we have talked about sort of the
disproportionate
um prosecution for those crimes so I
think this is a middle ground if there's
just a
current uh case that should be preceded
so to me this is a middle ground so when
it comes to the possession charges like
I I think if you right now you're
eligible for an inment if you were
convicted of a possession charge you had
three4 of an ounce or less I Envision
that three4 of an ounce or less changing
to a higher number one day I don't I
think the en nment section can get
rather
uh animated sometimes so I I was hoping
that for the sake of this bill whether
we do a state control model we can maybe
kick that can down the road is what I
was hoping to do when it comes to the
inment but I I think let's say the The
Possession limit is 2 ounces right we
should expand the analment section to 2
ounces consistent with the legal
possession right I think that that makes
sense
but I I would concur with that
assessment because that's consistent
with what the maximum possessory limit
would
be it's previously stated in the
proposed legislation and again careful
to be
uh allowing con uh en nments of
convictions of significant quantities of
marijuana that you don't want to have
anull and there's no charge for the
analment so that and that was something
P two terms
ago the um I think at this point a
possession with intent to distribute
distribution those those been those been
qualified
if I may yes yeah I just I feel like um
kicking this issue if I think this is a
fairness issue and I think this
provision uh is very fair particularly
if I mean this is someone just to to
reiterate we're going to be prosecuting
someone for something that's not illegal
anymore right so that this is a fairness
issue and I hear what you're saying
about you know this being potentially a
political hot button but I think this
commission is trying to get the best
possible
package here and if that's something
that the legislature is going to debate
down the road let's do that but from my
perspective as a commission looking
holistically at the problem I think this
is a piece of the puzzle that we can't
ignore it's fundamental fairness it it
is I I do agree that for any County
attorney out there that's Prosecuting a
claim that if you got a successful
conviction on that that conviction would
immediately be subject to an annulment
is a horrible use of discretion I I just
because literally you get the conviction
enters then you get the analment within
seconds
right yeah I very much agree with
Senator Whitley on this um and
particularly that it's a middle ground
we're not talking about resentencing
here which I think from our perspective
would be the most appropriate thing to
do um for all the folks who are
currently um facing penalties or living
through penalties because of uh what
we'll soon hopefully soon be legal um
and also I think there's sections in
this that are talking about
non-discrimination talking about you
know access to um engage in the business
aspect of this and so I think having the
inment piece as part of this ensuring
that folks have clean records so that we
go through this whole process um with
the Clean Slate I think is important um
and also just this the straight fact
that having a criminal conviction um
impacts housing impacts employment Etc
so I think the faster we can fix that um
what your showns have I'm I'm I'm with
you on that I just want to make sure
this doesn't apply this would apply to
manufacturing right so if someone's
illegally Manu is in
manufacturing I'm I'm not really sure
get into anymore but you know you get
what I'm saying right if someone's
transporting basically large quantities
right you know someone has an 18wheeler
full of cannabis like we're we're
talking like that to me falls under you
I I think that is one issue the simple
possession charges at the lower level
that's the stuff that's I'm I'm with you
so do we just need to clean that up to
exclude perhaps
the you know the Kingpin from this Am I
Wrong Am I Wrong Am I reading this
incorrectly
any I I agree with you Senator
that you should handle these simple
possession charges which I think it's a
myth that we have all these people in
jail and I would love love to hear from
the AG's office how many people we
actually have currently in incarcerated
for a simple possession charges if you
have that
stat I I don't have those numbers it's
not
many it's by manufacturing
right it doesn't say cultivating it we
from
represent my friend from Hudson that
there is a difference so manufacturing
yes manufacturing is included in there
uh but it also appears to be qualified
No More Than The Possession limit of
cannabis where the offense occur prior
to the statute going into effect that
possession limit means The Possession
limit as defined I I think that's
pointing to the provision earlier in
this section here it's not the same
provision so that may be a clerical
error um in terms of what sub paragraph
It's pointing
to but that may be the personal
possession limit that's articulated on
page three
um
or on page P five of the bill line
26 if that citation is a clerical error
so if you were doing if you were
transporting manufacturing but you're
under the you had three qu oun or less
so we're not talking about the 18 milon
correct okay good thank
you with that as long as we have the
appropriate uh
reference yeah maybe I think so that's
what I was trying to figure out if
that's yeah but if that's intended to be
pointing to the new possession limit uh
y right everyone's if everyone's anyone
against that just raise your hand for
read
three
right the only issue of paragraph three
is that it automatically vacates so so
this is it automatically vacates the
conviction all right in order for that
to be
issue the legislator can't
vacate the conviction we had that with
another analment bill
it's the bill involving the uh
um with the the Witchcraft D and
criminal justice public that that point
we had in Sate Judiciary this year so I
think paragraph three right now for the
The Possession for an analment a person
just has to apply and I'm not sure if it
can be done administratively I know self
board and Massachusetts it can be done
administratively but the court could at
their discretion schedule a hearing
but this says it's automatically vacated
without any finding to make sure that
they even qualify a you
know there's no charge for the
application in New Hampshire I remember
I wanted I was actually against getting
rid of the the $100 fee but it's I lost
out but to automatically do
it I mean that's a lot
of
May
well but it says that it's it's vacated
by operational
law right and I I think that's because
we're talking
about a crime that's not a crime
anymore yes but I'm just saying for
every other analment section I mean
witchcraft is not a crimeal either so we
don't we can't just retroactively can
the legislator actually vacate a
conviction by the court like when
there's a when there's an a state of
emergency the court technically doesn't
have to listen to the executive order
neither does the legislative brige so
they tend to line up correctly they tend
to all work together quite well but
that's more out of cooperation than
Mandy is it what's your proposal I'm
just I I'm just explaining that
mandating that it be vacated is that an
issue we can do that yeah and we have in
other
areas okay I'm not sure it was
constitutional men and was we're no
we're the legislature is the general
court Massachusetts calls it the great
and general court we are the
ultimate and we're for a long time the
law okay all right we're good I'm
outnumbered anyway so and and
if we are numbered anyway we can move on
um zero Senator sorry on that um are
there any issues too with criminal
records and uh making sure that the
court is talking to police or whoever
have crime records as well and making
sure that it's fully cleaned
up there should be I know in the the
analment language from the other it's in
there because part of the analment is it
it's sealed from all ways of finding the
only the only thing would remain if
there any news articles online otherwise
that would
include uh making sure it's not
accessible to the public police
time would you want to add that to this
yes so what I would homework assignment
is look for the other RSA and you want
consistent
thank
you
now it comes this has to do with the
revenue side of things before we debate
that my only take on that is no matter
what happens we're not going to all
agree that's a that's really for the
ways and means Comm to do I think for
the sake of whether there's a state run
model we don't we can we should punt on
that
well I would say to the extent that
there's
policy decisions within this Revenue
section we should
discuss anything specific that you want
to reference I just I know some not
everyone agreed on the some of the
revenue going to the um Statewide
education property taxs well we actually
went through that no concerns were
raised so if we so we went through
Senator on page
we went through um starting on page 27
we went through all of that all right
everyone's in board all
right
good excuse
me in Senator y we we did leave off uh
on that page I I just wanted to make a
comment uh I thought I was going to be
making it when when when we come back
that the revenue splits that we went
over what was on page 27
27 if you look at all the different
percentages um I I think that the
percentage going to to the treatment
prevention and
uh recovery side should be a lot lot
larger than what we looking at the split
um when when Dr Silver spoke I think she
was talking about uh rule of thumb was
that out of all revenues that are
collected what is it 30% should be going
to uh fixing or trying to uh manage the
harms that you know legalize a marijuana
costs so so so I I agree with you on a
on a principal basis when I put the bill
in last term in the house the original
Revenue share I had was the first
million in net revenue would go towards
go to DHHS for drug treatment programs
and you know it's a long a bunch of sub
inclusions in there and then then there
was the split otherwise the problem was
was that I didn't really get much um
support I guess testimony and support of
DHHS justifying that expenditure meaning
if they came to the committee and
explained what that money would be used
for it's $25 million a year and explain
all the the things that could be done
with it that was where that kind of sank
so that they reduced it to about 10%
which um might not have been as as much
revenue to them but so I guess my
question just when it gets to the
politics and the legislator they're
going to want to say all right you're
giving x amount what are they going to
use it for they need they need to come
they need to come in and explain to
everyone and sell it because I I a good
just following up on that uh 80% of the
the allocations here would be to
non-public health or Public Safety
amount um so just refining that a little
bit more if it's the the take from this
is 15% then that would be 3% of the the
total commercial activity would be set
aside for public health and Public
Safety so that would be an order
magnitude different than what Dr Silver
had had referenced
would also note that there there aren't
other
um aspects here uh that would probably
demand additional funding if the
enforcement is supposed to be here so
for example the state lab there's there
is no funding additional funding here
for the state lab there is some the 5%
um set aside for the Dr and aide uh
training um if the enforcement
mechanisms that are included here would
be envisioning additional testing than
that the lab wouldn't be able to handle
that without additional resources and so
maybe on that issue um
maybe if you wanted to work with the
various departments and looking I mean
you could present a proposal I think to
the commission for adjusting the
percentages I think that might make a
lot of
sense what and I think letting that be
fought out in way and they going have to
fight it out again in way and means
anyway is my point but I don't think
anyone's wrong what they're saying I
don't either but I would but and I I
guess from a policy perspective I would
like to hear sort of what the state
thought was an
appropriate amount
sen if I can regarding regarding the fee
for the labs and everything the
manufacturer is going to pay for some of
this as well and that's a factor that
hasn't been taken into the cost of of of
the labs there's going to be a a charge
to the manufacturer
for the testing and that should cover a
good section of it the uh
presumed massive amount of testing
that's going to take
place may be a little
um
enthusiastically described because
people are now going to be getting a
product from a secure
establishment and the tracking of the
that particular product is being done by
the the coding that we talked about when
we were talking them in the tracking
section so the lab's not going to get
involved in that unless the end the
product that is uh found at the scene of
a anciliary crime or a motor vehicle
incident or something like that uh
doesn't match up with the tracking
number that would be on the packaging so
that would that would cause the lab to
get involved but the lab would be
involved in that in any case
so it's not in addition to normal
use it's I think that the the concern
about funding the lab is a
little
little misplaced one of the concerns
with the lab funding was you didn't want
when you have prosecutions for that you
know opioids or you know whatever those
labs are already behind schedule so
adding cannabis to that we hoping to not
overcrowded so if they the state wishes
to engage in their to have their backup
testing in well the state's going to be
engaged in that anyways so as a followup
to the commercial lab testing that's
going to be taking place and in addition
the state is always uh uh can engage in
the business of uh charging for uh it's
fee in the labs however it seems to me
that uh using this as a justification
for more money is a little disingenuous
when you can say the state is behind in
our testing because we don't have enough
man uh Manpower or person power we don't
have enough equipment we don't have
enough um facility to to handle the the
DraStic increase that I think
particularly when we're dealing with the
opio crisis that's going on has a a
stronger
appeal remember this is all a political
appeal so if you're going to do it that
way do it that way just I had to I had
the opportunity uh during the break to
talk to uh the director of the lab and I
enforc
and and just one other point
was to have to have the prevention side
of things have to justify the amount I
think we it the wrong way because we're
not we're not looking at what we're not
looking the same way when we're saying
about the retirement or or the
educational fund um I think what we
should do is leave that as we discussed
at an earlier meeting to the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
for them to decide what would be best
for our state to use that money and I'm
I'm I'm positive they would tell you
that uh they there's many uses for that
money and that uh it's it's not going to
be like they're going to have too much
and have a
you just a a quick I gu qualification
less to the commercial testing of of
product and more to
the envisioned Demand on on labs for
testing um samples relating to
prosecution so if the assumption is that
there will be no increased consumption
in the state and impaired driving won't
increase at all under under this then
then that's I guess one question but if
there's an assumption that there will be
an increased usage of cannabis in the
state and a corresponding increase in
impaired driving proportionate to that
then I think that that's where it's
policy decision in terms of right sizing
funding to ensure that the enforcement
mechanism for DUI enforcement is Right
sized to the amount of of consumption
and potential impaired d driving so I
think that that's that was my context
for um for demands on the state lab and
enforcement and that money going to
State lab this the extra funding that
goes will help could help with
prosecution of opioid cases too so part
of the problem is that's already I don't
know under funding they're underst staff
whatever you want to say it's already
operating on fumes so giving it in in
addition to the burden this could put on
them it's still serving a function by
helping them if you don't get those
results fast enough yet you will get
your case thrown out well yeah timely
timely you know prosecution yeah cuz
we're not California we're take six
years to process a jaywalking complaint
um
but I'm I'm still of the opinion that uh
rather than trying to tie it to this
bill you tie it to the overall need
because they there definitely is an
overall the I'm not
against uh funding the lab more uh any
more than I am about putting more
cruises on the highway because we keep
killing people
um you know let's let's do it for the
right reasons you're on the house Ways
and Means Committee uh unfortunately
ready we let that this rematch well not
only that but there's several others on
both sides of the aisle that will come
up with a similar
discussion be to to justify that but I
think for the sake of the bill going
forward for the commission I think we
page so this is uh this would basically
make the existing
therapeutic stores assuming they remain
just a therapeutic store it would let
them be a for-profit entity is that
does
want
Therapeutics don't we want don't we want
the therapeutic programs to fall under
uh yeah we do I do well that was that
was the conversation we ended with last
time I wasn't sure if I missed anything
this this morning when I wasn't here so
we didn't talk about that oh well how
about this that's that was very animated
would save that for the end because we
just I think we're almost done going
through the
draft so could we but for the sake of
this this was a bill that passed I think
we it got vetoed and was sustained by
term
but we we'll cover we'll cover that
again I'm back okay can you go back for
me for one minute just on sure with the
shall be vacated in the May so it shall
be vacated would be line 19 is that next
the 1 May is that going to become a
shell take any administrative action
is it all becoming shell now for the
first two so you have sh be vacated on
19 are we changing on 20 to Shell take
judicial
action that's that's I thought you would
come up with the two shells so let's say
you have the conviction on your record
they're saying it's vacated as a matter
of law yep so perhaps your background
check if someone were to check to see a
conviction may still appear on there
because the administrative process of
vacing hasn't been done yet and that's
my point is that this is not going to go
back to just people convicted in the
last 10 years they can be convicted in
you know 50 years ago and they're going
to have to go back and so I would leave
it at May because you know not that it's
even if you think it was an injustice
with all due respect going back 70
years requiring the court to do that may
take some time okay thank you well not
only that but as you're aware getting
records expunged is
Hampshire any issue with number 42 sorry
line 42 that's paragraph 18 goes up to
page is that language just being change
because if you're going to be a
for-profit entity the titles of the
mind thank you Mr chairman for the
record Matt Simon Granite Leaf cannabis
I'm not an expert on this section
necessarily but I can help you
understand where it's coming from so
everything beginning on page
32 uh line 32 so paragraph 17 paragraph
18 19 20 21 22 23 and 24 so all the way
to the middle of page 35 uh that is
all uh what used to be Standalone
legislation in 2019 it was SB 145 and
2021 it was
sb38 and I believe the only changes have
been to the dates but the whole section
envisions A for-profit conversion
opportunity for the atcs so it's
identical language that was the one vote
uh I believe so I believe the language
is identical thank you sorry for
that so section I'm sorry Matt sections
we will now be on line 22 of page 35
here can I go back in history with you
man for a
second just so I remember if I remember
correctly six years ago and maybe I
brought this up one other time the whole
idea behind the dispensaries right we
were going to have a medicinal place and
you guys were then going to have sort of
an advantage since she'd be set up in
place you and so we did and you guys I
thought had said that you would never
want to become a Comm commercial enter
you know selling am I remembering this
wrong from six years ago I thought you
always wanted to stay therapeutic you'd
never get into the sale of recreational
cannabis and then you guys had said
since we're going to have this Advantage
we'll never do that am I remembering
that wrong Senator I have no
recollection of that I'll clarify I've
only worked for granite LEF for about
two and a half years so six years ago I
was in a completely different role but I
do not remember anybody saying that I do
remember the atc's repeatedly saying
that they could serve patients better if
they were able to operate on a
you all right so back to uh section 25
on page 35 section 25 on page 35
beginning on line 22 any issue
straightforward
ask a question um this is to The Liquor
Commission do you feel like you all
would need a name
change liquor and cannabis
commission I don't think I don't feel
that's necessary still want to be a
Liquor Commission I think that would
be maybe one day well it's we're not
really dealing in the in the retail part
of it other than overseeing I see the
the franchise piece so it's would be I
would consider a two separate
entities with the oversight being from
the
commission also the the so the New
Hampshire Li have a great did a great
job with their branding identity and
um just similar to our oversight of
you
yeah
yes uh paragraph three under paragraph
25 that would be line
warrant
so if I can I can speak that quickly uh
that language just mirrors the language
that's in the liquor statute that the
liquor commissioner or the Deputy
Commissioner can go into any
establishment at any time and speak it's
it's mainly to speak with the owner
their business partners we go in and
speak with them about their business
it's not a search and seizure type of
operation it's more of a
partnership question question and answer
anything we can help you with are we
doing the right things or how are we
doing as a business how else can we help
you uh thank you for putting that on the
record um as you the senator is well
aware there's a certain group of
individuals that will spot that and uh
so it's not a fourth amendment issue
because by simply by getting the license
you are agreeing to this search I just I
that's fine I want put that on the
record C when they see it remind them
that if you don't want to be searched at
random don't ask for a license or permit
to sell or manufacture cannabis thank
you for putting that up that description
forward uh now we have it where it
sir in on page 35 beginning line 41
that's under par section 26 ran numeral
2 that's just the opportunity for to
chairman I obviously you want to have a
prosecutor perhaps that is custom with
Prosecuting these types of cases that
makes sense that's pretty common that's
section
I'm skipping down to I'm sorry I have to
leave um but I'm skipping down briefly
yes we this is a retail
tobacco an
existing tobacco retailer now is allowed
to sell
so but they would still have to get a
separate franchise right that has to do
with the licenses I mean sorry that the
um that has to do with
paraphernalia oh got it and the reason
is is that you know cannabis
paraphernalia and tobacco paraphernalia
are very hard to distinguish from each
other I mean they're actually basically
the same thing for the most
right well that's why that's how they
get around now I see I just yeah I
see I apologize Mr chair I have to go
get my son at
school me first well we were GNA have
that animated discussion that we left
off with last hearing but um if you want
to listen from afar and I'm sure um I'm
not sure I want my 10-year-old to listen
to that conversation Mr chair the I'm
sure the senator from District 23 will
uh read it present any messages on your
behalf perhaps would you want to hold it
until Senator Lang and I are back we we
can but we're not going to make a final
decision for the anyone so um but next
meeting I want to say he going to be our
we got to have some consensus done so um
but we'll just finish for the I think we
so I would hope we get the effective
date right after all the work we put in
the money for the uh public the $500,000
that's just in there twice so page 37
lines 1 to three on Roman
okay
so I would probably want to just strike
lines one through three on page 37 does
that make sense there new new Futures
here I don't want to get mad at
me Senator Whitley just left and then we
strike
there provision but that's the same are
that
okay
longoi so which one are we striking then
we would strike paragraph three and
paragraph four removing them on page 27
on page 27 okay removing them
to section
paragraphs
pars so just to clarify lines 21 through
28 on page 27 are being stricken and the
appropriation different years though we
all agree on that just wanted to it is
two different years recognize it is June
of 24 and then June of
million I I think that line 40 is a typo
because all the other dates are 2025 in
this section so I think that's just a
typo well when we come back when we make
the revisions make sure that we're not
okay we'll leave it for now but with the
understanding for next time there is a
be earlier you don't put Appropriations
when you're establishing fund you
section
EST
that
okay Senator I'll check the numbers just
to make sure that the numbers are
the all right just clarify that but all
right
so
is that a title I think so if you look
at line 40 on page
36 the date is June 30th
2024 all the other dates are June 30th
2025 so I think that that might just be
a
typo
immediately well we'll double I I we'll
double check that but I think you I I
saying could I'll just state that Mr
chair that well that work will start
immediately upon passage of the bill so
I I'm not going to argue to the dates
but there there'll be need for funding
to get to get that work started let's
just say that's all let's just say this
bill whatever bills whatever it becomes
law signed into
1 they won't have any money to get
started that's correct so I I feel it's
9 million now someone may may say that's
too high but I think the idea is all
right we got to get started if we
wait
well they're not going to have I mean
that's one way to stop government
actions by not funding it don't you
20th maybe I don't I'm I'm just pointing
out that I think what the commission
what he commissioner saying is he needs
that they without money to do it they're
going to be just sitting there waiting
and that hurts everyone that I mean we
saw that happen with some of the atcs
some of their administrative rules takes
two years to get what was it a lot
except the out ofate uh therapeutic
cards how long that take one year two
years one and a half a long time way too
long that's that's the answer right so
we don't we don't want them sitting
around
because there will be a lot of moving
parts so I think we got to be careful
with we're not going to just throw money
at it but we don't want to also I guess
handcuff the project or set up a failure
yeah I'm wondering if it'd be
appropriate I understanding I don't
understand the exact amount they'll need
to get this process started but having
it impact or having it go into effect
upon passage because the 30mon clock
from the rule making all that starts
right when this passes and so yeah
making sure that they have the funds
right away to get started because the
clock is taking right off the bat for
them correct that's what I'm
saying
all right
so I think was there anything animated
that we need to discuss I know there was
issues with the possession I think we
should wait for Senator Lang and Senator
Whitley to be here for that um did I was
late so I apologize but did we discuss I
know Dr younger's not here but did she
have any info on that n
nanograms I mean others will probably
correct me if I'm misspeaking here but
she basically said that there's no
scientific number there's no magic
number for what that what so what
intoxication is no I know not
intoxication but it's a per se limit I
think was we talked about some states
that do have yeah some states have it
but that there's no there's no
scientific backing for having a per se
limit without getting to the details of
my body composition I'm 215 pounds how
many grams of Edibles would a 2115 pound
person have to be at like five DS that's
what I was trying to get it one of the
things she was talking about was that it
really depends on how much you use so
someone who's I like I don't use
marijuana so the first time I took an
edible I'd have high levels but if
someone was a chronic user they take the
same amount as me weigh the same as me
have a much no it's going to vary from
person to person I'm just saying my my
only problem is I'm just as a the legal
mind of me saying if I want to advise
someone how to comply with the law how
do I do it well it's not I'm not saying
that they're impaired because they're
nanograms are at five but how do how
does someone know well if I use this
much I'm going to pass I we well no does
anyone there's nothing on that at all
well we we we just had this state
trooper you know get get killed over on
the Sea Coast or whatever and is as you
all read that the gentleman pleed guilty
when THC was found in his his blood and
we have a we have a dead guy right a
dead sea Trooper all right I I I'm not
saying that that person wasn't inair
but if you have a per se limit you need
to know how much you got to take to
reach that limit at
least yeah I think that was the concern
was not to have a per se limit and to
have as like I have a whole host of
things that are available so that like
Dr test like David have the the universe
there Chief and Mr chair it's not the
level it's the behavior yes and that's
the behavior can be whether you're
alcoholic um if you're a chronic
alcoholic you can operate pretty well at
0.12 but you're you're violating the law
on a on a PR Prima fascia basis but
you're still driving in a straight line
and stopping in plenty of time whereas
uh a
17-year-old at
02 going to have a little bit of
difficulty uh so it's it's the behav
Behavior not the level and I don't think
we should get caught up in a level
because even though we have one for
alcohol we there isn't one for uh um Mar
or cannabis there isn't one for Valium
there isn't one for uh um the lotted and
those are prescription drugs that people
drive with day in and day out no I I
understand Chief my I'm I agree with you
to the extent that I can't figure out
how to advise some some to comply with
the law if we can get to the point where
we can provide some ballpark realm where
we can tell someone if you're using this
amount you may strug otherwise I mean
it's I don't think
it's well if I may uh for the benefit of
the discussion that we had earlier is
the difference between per se limit and
and a primma fascia case uh the per se
limit like we used to alcohol breath
test is a Hardline limit uh the the
expectation is is that if you hit
0.08 um that the presumption is is that
you're impaired okay with marijuana
there is no scientific limit right as
you rightly indicated uh and the science
is still uh widely variant with respect
to um impairment uh by various levels of
THC
content the states that have walked the
narrow path between the two
have looked at
Alternatives such as a primma fashion
limit which is only an additional limit
or additional element excuse me that
would be included along with the other
observable evidence developed in a DUI
case such as the officer's observations
uh the officer's uh information evidence
that may be obtained similar to open
containers let me so just to rephrase
this so if let's say the number was five
nanograms and if you tested positive for
five nagr or six so you're over that
limit that's only evidence of impairment
where as opposed to alcohol it you know
8 or higher you are impairment that that
would be correct it would be essentially
in your legal terminology a rebut it
would create a rebuttable
presumption uh that would shift the
burden from the state back to the
operator um for the judge to consider it
would not not be uh the overarching
requirement for for for intoxication is
that how your office interpreted that in
terms of the the testimony today and and
uh whether a limit would be workable as
as evidence of impairment as opposed to
conclusive per se limit yes that would
be consistent with how other states
operate um in in terms of prosecutions
whether it
I guess the allocation of the bur that's
yeah my mistake was I was I was I was
thinking per per se so I I think uh just
one flag if we were to make this even
like a rebuttable presumption is that
rebuttable presumption would be based on
something that's not scientifically
valid um because there is no consensus
on that issue and so if we were to make
up a number five or 10 or whatever that
is it still be making a number out of
thin air because there's no science
behind that number and so the create a
reable presump assumtion to put a burden
on someone to have to prove a negative
in that case would be problematic and so
I think that's why it's really important
that we look at this like we do with
opioids or other prescription drugs that
you know there's a totality of things
that happened in that that the officer
can document and then testify about and
then it's and then I think it's really
important that in the funding stream
that we are funding the Dr programs and
giving State Police and others the
resources they'll need to be able to
have folks available to do that no in
color I I I appreciate what you're
saying how do you rebut a presumption if
the science isn't there to do it in the
first place if the science was there we
probably would be able to write a more
clearer law uh so in Colorado I know
they kind of I think that was the first
state that kind of came up with this
plan what do they have a rebuttable
presumption what do they
do chief there there I I believe but I I
would have to fact check this uh I
believe that they are more in a prima
fascia uh
uh realm in other words they've set a
they've sent a limit that is simply a
presumption that the person may be
impaired by cannabis at that limit uh it
is not a per se limit in in the sense
that it uh results in an automatic or uh
irrevocable uh determination the point
uh with due respect uh to my colleague
here is that people are impaired by
cannabis it doesn't comp how they
operate a motor vehicle right so to set
to say that there is no limit is wildly
viciously inaccurate uh impairment is
proven by cannabis by multitudes of
studies uh and you can watch those on on
video if you like right and people
driving through cones uh that knock the
cones all over the place the point of
the matter is Right does the state want
in the likelihood of significant
increased
motorists operating Motor Vehicles on
the roads of the State of New Hampshire
that have consumed cannabis and become
involved in a wreck or could potentially
become involved in a wck or as we
discussed earlier where there is no
obser observation because you arrive at
the scene of a wreck and uh you have an
operator and there's no observation the
operator may have been taken to the
hospital so what do you have left uh if
it's a SBI or fatal you have a blood
test that's mandated under law currently
right and it comes back uh if the person
is showing um quantities of other
illicit drugs that is considered by the
judge uh in making a determination uh
and I'm sure that you've represented a
number of people in those cases uh this
simply sets a a standard by which some
degree of impairment
indicates that the person could have
been impaired and should be included
with other facts and information along
with the case because impairment by
cannabis isn't isn't is a
fact I'm with I'm not I'm not against
the premise of it I'm just saying when
when I the people that I represent that
violate the law I'd like to kind of give
them my heads up on how to comply with
it that's what I'm getting at and the
problem is and I had the same I had the
issue I raised before with the open
container part and all I'm saying is I I
think we need to come up with something
but for the sake of the bill we're
putting together is it is it going to go
in
here Ju Just So let you know just in
Colorado the limit Colorado for active
Delta 9C in a driver's blood which gives
rise to a permissible
inference uh that the person is under
the influence of can cannabis it's five
nanograms or more per milliliter in the
whole blood so I
in court it's a permissible inference
but it's not per se is there and
Colorado if you look at their stats on
traffic fatalities and and wrecks since
they've legalized weed it's through the
roof I mean they're not really a stellar
example of how to be doing things no no
I listen in Colorado keep in mind when
they legalize this they're not
surrounded by anyone else doing it where
we surrounded on all sides so I think
the the statistical impact I get it and
it's but I'm just saying
there's going to be people that violate
the law who might not even realize
they're doing it and that's what I'm
worried there's going to be people that
intentionally VI there's people that
drink and drive and they just do it they
don't care there but someone like myself
I'm aware what legal liit is I know my
body way I can do the math and you know
I have a well I can have one drink but
not two right before you know you it's
kind of close right with this how do you
tell someone how could someone like Dr
youngren who's not here but how could
would you tell a patient hey this is
what it is you just I'm just saying
there's no way to I'm trying to map it
out and I don't see it there there's
there's an e easy way to not violate the
law don't smoke and drive smoking and
driving is a separate that's a separate
offense because you're using it while
you're drive while you're actually
driving what I'm saying is there's an
accident right single car accident they
do a they do a blood test on the driver
all right they're can then get the
results of that blood test and if you
have this measurement in your blood keep
in mind that person may not have used
anything for a week now that probably
means when you when you sit down at the
black jab table you're putting your
money on the line right you're not
guaranteed to get a good hand or win I
think if you want to choose to smoke
weed you're GNA have to deal with the
consequences no I I'm I'm with you on
that but I'm just saying how much weed
does someone smoke to reach the five
nanograms no one knows one hit and
one have a one glass of wine and get
behind the wheel and not be at
08 so what we're doing really is just
legalizing impairment that's what it
comes down to no no look what I'm saying
is if you just smoke and then drive
you're you're you know as people say hi
I get it if you don't do anything for a
week you may still have cannabis in your
system and I'm that's the person how do
you distinguish that person who from so
I have a question for you from the
person who just smoked and drove that
I'm with you on that 100% how do you
drag someone in I don't want to drag
someone in who hasn't done anything for
a week but it's not the over archering
and defining element for proving up a a
conviction that's why in Colorado it's
it's the permissible limit right it's
not the overarching limit I think we're
getting we're getting wrapped around the
axle with uh hard line 08 versus the
state who may have invested interest in
public health and Public Safety on the
highway simply stating we are going to
add an element which couldn't be
considered by the judge and the judge
the Trier fact gives whatever way he or
she wishes to that information coupled
with the other evidence in the case
Frank any question but is five a number
that perhaps is well we heard testimony
today that the NIH did a study uh that
reflected that um uh 30,000 U
respondents that reflected impairment at
three
nanograms I mean I think going off of
what we heard from the doctor there is
no magic number and I think that's
that's the problem and I think that's
why it's really important that we invest
in Dr you know law enforcement know how
sorry
and either way we should probably have
a this needs to be somehow studied we're
all representatives of our people that
of the State of New Hampshire this guy
is not well we we we decide what's best
for the people of New
Hampshire I understand that but we want
to do public advisory stuff and we need
to advise people of certain things
and I'm just explaining you may have
Canabis already illegal it's already
illegal to drive with certain
prescription drugs all right so no
you're for no
change I mean not adding that nanogram
on no you don't need any nanogram on
there because you've already got the
entire situation of the stop to take
into consideration the guy's bouncing
between yellow and white you're going to
stop him I would hope I think that you
can
perhaps maybe were we were we word
different than Colorado what if we word
it in a way that it said it may be
evidence thereof if someone's
measurements over this no because
Colorado can't build a straight road
from the city to the
airport
just just to let you know I'm just
giving information not advocating for
Colorado but just to
clarify um I read what the law was and
this is from uh DWI attorney the best uh
that says to prove you guilty of DUI and
marijuana to
prose who will need to show that you
were actually too ston to drive safely
such evidence might include just like
any traffic stop you violated the
traffic laws you're weaving in out of
Lane you drove too fast or slow you
appear stoned blood bloodshot eyes
slurred speech the officer smelled
marijuana in the C the uh there was
marijuana paraphernalia in the vehicle
rolling papers all that marijuana was
found in youra but it goes on to say
that a permissible inference just
because you have that it doesn't mean
it's proof of guilt it's just something
that the judge can consider in the way
we're talking about Dres I I agree with
you we need the training please don't
get me wrong but the way we're uh
talking about di is it's it's almost
like we don't even need if you take all
that if you take all that for granted
everything that's been said it's it's
like
we don't even need laws for alcohol
limits if we have Dres that's not how it
works you you need you still need some
tools to be able to uh combat uh imper
driving so it's Dres are going to help
but there's a lot of other things that
go into it including getting the
educational piece out there to the
public so now could it have the reverse
effect no ST he's offsite way in um
could it have the reverse effect so
let's say the person all over the place
they ran over the
cones rise a
bloodshot slur speech they take a blood
test and they come back at you know
point point or four nanograms
right then it's going to go the other
way right now it's exculpatory
evidence it could it depends on um
whether or not that permissible
inference whatever that that level is is
perceived as being definitive so um any
any level
either for blood alcohol content or for
um intoxication from from drugs will be
both over inclusive and under inclusive
so uh the level of intoxication that
someone may be at in terms of impairment
of ability to drive a vehicle at Point
uh
08 may be different for different
individuals it's a per se limit in the
statute and it's um and so that has a
consequence I think that the the issue
or difference with uh the intoxication
from uh THC is that that level of
difference of impairment is it's broader
uh that range is is wider and so it may
be less informative there and it's just
whether or not it's perceived by the
finder a fact that it is determinative
if it is at that or above that range I I
think it's just really important to
remember I think none of us here are
advocating for people to drive and paed
I think we're trying to figure out the
effective way to deal with this issue
and I I think it's just really important
to remember from the science that there
is no number and so if we are going to
try and create a number we have to
recognize that we are literally just
pulling it out of thin air because
there's no science to back it up um so I
think you know we need to figure out how
to address this but it's not just the
number it's how does what a person
arrive at the number what are they doing
to get to that number in the first place
and that's all science starts with a
hypothesis we we just need to start with
one and pick a number all science starts
question so two things one is you know
you you keep discussing about what does
it take to get to the Limit right well
there's no difference in
that hypothesis with someone who
is your physique height and weight that
uses different types of alcohol at a bar
right and then is trying to determine
the difference between having two
glasses of wine or three shots or four
shots of 40% alcohol or 60% alcohol it's
the same thing right there is no magic
number there is no chart that says on
the wall of a bar or dis place that
dispenses alcohol that says if you have
four shots of this and you weigh 215
pounds you're going to be 008 right so
let's dispense with that for a moment
because I think that's a farsal argument
uh the the the last thing I'll I'll say
is this no one in this
room other than me my people have to go
to a family and tell that family that
the person that just plowed into the
back of your husband who was 34
nanograms from milliliter of cannabis
and launched them in the back of a van
and killed them could not get a
conviction for
at Chief I I appreciate what you're
saying but 34 and three is such a it's
just different I but I'm not I
understand what you're saying but 30
three so I'm not I'm just saying if we
made that number if it's three is it
five it's it seven when it comes to the
Committees in the legislator I'm not
talking about in the I understand what
you're saying but when we present this
policy whether it's and the house
criminal justice committee the Senate
Judiciary Committee these are the
questions that they're going to ask and
all I'm trying to get at is if we had a
number what that appropriate number is
and really putting that into the context
of what a person is how much they would
it be ingesting to get to that point I'm
not try trying to you're never going to
get there take away from what you're
saying because there is no there is no
number we need to justify the number
whatever line the sand we we come to we
just I think explanation I just have to
say there is no number and this is the
most irresponsible dangerous legislation
that I have ever participated in it's
very disappointing because we are going
to increase death addiction and it it's
it's a
travesty well I I appreciate the
comments all right I'm
not I've seen other versions of this
these legislations that I've would say
had some pre agre of stuff in there
right we're trying to minimize some of
those negative impacts can we do it 100%
no so which before we debate if we want
to debate the morals of legalizing or
not the commission's direction our
directive of this commission is to put
together legislation for State operated
a state controlled model okay I
understand to some people on here that
we don't necessarily support
legalization right and I I can say with
um and I'm sure my friends in the
industry here I'm not even sure they
consider me a friend because I've did so
much work helping defeat canis
legislation as a
legislator I was the one vote by the way
for that nonprofit but the states that
set those limits and there's uh more
than several I'm just saying I'm set a
limit under the same circumstances that
you're discussing they don't have a
scientific limit but when when when
saying irresponsible we're we're
contributing to that there's no one
who's who's been analyzing the potential
negative impacts of cannabis
since that I've been in the legis I
think I take first place all right in my
two terms in the house and in the Senate
and I look at everything we can to
minimize all these impacts because I
look at what's happening around us and
it is a problem there's people using
drugs there's opioids all right don't
think I don't know anyone that's passed
away from drug overdoses I think I even
lost friends to that so when you say
that I'm encouraging that I find it
insultive it's not I do find it
insulting so I'm telling you I'm just
being honest with
you dis you are four times more likely
it's
a to opioid disorder we will see we to
see our already over those death rates
increase that is sence and what do we do
about all the New Hampshire plates that
you go sit in all these dispensaries and
they're everywhere so the Reaper Madness
everyone talks about is here already I
see it all the time I even smell when
I'm walking around outside so there are
problems I get it and and what we're
trying to do is actually do this not
like every other state all right but if
that's the commission here the charge of
this commission is to put together that
legislation okay and that that's what
we're here to do all right so I
understand there's some negative this
there is some negative social impacts of
course I get
it uh with that being said moving on to
the next subject since we don't have a
consensus on how to have the measurement
um analyzed
yet uh the other animated subject I'm
glad our friends from the atcs are here
was the concept
of if with the Dual licenses where
suppose an ATC wanted to become a retail
store how would that work out and where
would their their regulation fall
under is there a consensus on that issue
and if you guys just want to take the
microphone while you're here um I think
the idea was they are voluntarily asking
to become a retail ja store no one's
making them do
anything they fill out the
application they get
approved I didn't like the idea of them
having two signs in one
store but the idea was they they would
um they're not guaranteed to get
approved but they would obviously make a
very um appealing candidate given their
experience in the industry but they
would lose their store
fund and then the idea was well if
they're going to be they have experience
in manufacturing you know would say
therapeutic grade
products the long-term branding is not
their store it's the product right
perhaps allowing the other retail stores
at their discretion if they choose to
sell a contract with them would be
permitted to distribute ATC products as
well but we would kind of leave the
three existing manufacturers shall we
say um maybe consider them grandfathered
in
and and then my other concern was uh and
I don't mean this as a knock or any
disrespected DHHS but you have liquor
who would be in charge of enforcement of
the retail side of things yet they would
have their retailers or their
franchisees selling products they have
no control of the regulation of and I
thought that that from the public
perspective they see cannabis it's
cannabis so that would create confusion
and by putting the DHHS rulem for
Therapeutics under liquor I think it
would kind of unify everything and
hopefully eliminate any potential
inconsistencies only thing remaining on
DHHS would be the license or the sorry
the therapeutic cards like that
procedure so you're basically taking it
and reassigning it under a different
that for better for worse
so so again I'm not saying your support
does not mean you support the the
underlying Bill itself but in consider
if the this became law would you rather
there be dual licenses I think if you're
G to have a a franchise who's offering
who's purchasing a franchise from the
state for them to sell their own
products and have their sign in their
creates and unfair Market Advantage for
the atcs they're asking to be retail
their choice they're not we're not
forcing them to give it up they're decid
they're asking they're basically
voluntarily doing but in exchange for
that you know their brand product but I
also think that for the therapeutic
program it allows it to
have some uh more ways to distribute
their product
um if I'm not Mis mistaken the way it
works with an alternate Treatment Center
is you advise the client as to which
type of product would best suit their
prescriptive need that is given to you
by say Pain Solutions or one of the pain
management companies uh for
example uh whether it's to increase
appetite whether it's to relieve pain or
something of that nature so that is an
advisory type of activity by the
alternate treatment centers whereas the
recreational stuff is we got this for
sale you buy whatever you
want uh to be crude about it but
that's basically what you're talking
about having operate is that
correct I think if you allow only some
atcs to sell the I mean sorry some
retail stores or franchises to sell
therapeutic products and not others the
problem is that's an unfair Market
advantage that's my problem and that it
it how do you resolve that now at the
same
time well they they're also not
obligated to sell their therapy to
product to other stores but the other
stores have the opportunity to do that
but in exchange they're going to give up
their storefront I think that that's a
pretty good exchange it's all being done
voluntarily
but they like this storefront trust me
and they want to keep
it yeah one ask I mean but I I think
from a policy exchange that that's not
um
outrageous
and speak freely thank you Mr chairman
again for the record Matt Simon Granite
Leaf cannabis and I'll add Brandon y uh
Brandon Pollock I am excuse me with h
tascal wellness and Keenan blums right
behind us also Granite Leaf cannabis
just wanted to draw your attention we
did circulate a memo earlier pass that
out it's the one titled integrating the
TCP and
atc's with the franchise model and
there's also an attachment with some
some uh possible Bill language uh that
goes along with that we didn't pass them
out together so you may have trouble
finding them both and putting together
sorry about that uh but thank you for
the opportunity to comment uh we we've
looked at this from a number of
perspectives we've participated and
observed all of these discussions it
seems to us that there are three
possible ways to integrate the TCP and
the atc's with the franchise model one
is a dual regulatory structure uh uh one
would be moving everything thing under
the lior commission and one would be uh
what the chairman just referred to which
would be sort of a hybrid approach where
DHHS would maintain a role in issuing
the cards in maintaining the patient
registry and and uh overseeing perhaps
the education and support we provide to
registered patients uh but all the
business regulation would move under the
Liquor Commission so we would not be in
any sense serving two masters from a
business perspective that seedling to
sale regulation would be handed handled
by The Liquor Commission in light of the
conversations we've heard we think that
may be the most logical approach um if
the commission if the study commission
does want to move forward with that
approach uh we would then want to do the
work of going through 126x and and
noting all the things that would need to
to change to make these uh uh the
franchise model consistent with the
existing law we think that's manageable
if DHHS is still handling the registry
and ID cards a big chunk of the
therapeutic canvas law can remain
relatively untouched and uh the business
sections would require some
modifications
so
um any comments comments on that so far
we
can Qui question for me probably at
least knowledgeable up here um so you're
going to be able to sell stuff up to
like a 98% THC to therapeutic patients
only who come in with the card right and
then you you'll sell to someone else who
comes in just
for cons regular consumption a product
that's going to be limited to 15% and
we'll have or something whatever the
number is so there are no potency limits
in the therapeutic canvas law uh and
there are no potency limits in terms of
percentage for inhalables in the draft
that we've seen I'm not aware of the
study commission ever ever doing that
it's actually left to Ru making to
determine what potency limits would be
but I I believe the essence of what
you're asking is correct that that that
would still still be the case how long
has the ru making
uh the ru making Authority been in
place for the therapeutic program it's
been in place uh well was created by the
law that passed in 2013 and uh the rules
were I believe finished in 2015 so like
for my my point is that the rul making
in respect to that
I guess when it comes to enforcement of
that you know a lot of that's going to
fall under
liquor it's just going to get it's not
getting eliminated it's just getting
taken out and put in here you're picking
up and moving it you're talking about
the regulation of businesses I believe
that would all move under liquor the
question of potency restrictions whether
they exist or not what they would be I
think that's a decision either to be
made in statute or as is currently the
case left of rulemaking I think I may
actually be in agreement with the
prevention folks that it would be better
to decide in statute that would provide
a lot of clarity to businesses on what
they're actually getting into if uh no I
I agree um I'm just my my point is to
the extent that that's subject to rul
making if they're going to enforce the
potency limits being sold in the store
shouldn't they be involved in the rul
making process for what the potency is
if that's the case if we don't legislate
it that's what I'm getting at that's
that's why I like the idea of putting it
all in one is I think some of the rules
it's you know they'll they will look at
it and when it comes to them regulating
they understand what they need to do
we've seen that successfully done with
alcohol in many ways I know there's laws
as well so they kind of compliment each
other but the only some does anyone have
a problem with that I mean I think when
it comes to do you qualify for a
therapeutic card and we keep track of
it I think we I think we we G we give it
to an agency that that has a proven
track record of of doing things smoothly
and correctly and regulating
and and yeah maybe maybe we let the
folks over at DHHS still hand out their
little card but it's going to be less
and less people getting a card you know
it's already down from 20,000 to 13,000
that's going to drop to like 5,000 so
you know that'll go away too it it may
be a time where that changes but I think
to the in the
interim is any so that just understand
that from the the ATC perspective
there's no objection to that
um no objection
what yeah we we'd love to see draft
language to be able to say there's no
objection uh but uh the concept the
concept sounds agreeable as I'm
understanding
it all right so I
think for the commission perspective do
we have any problem if anyone has a
problem that ra just put your hand
up
no
going to be setting a limit for
recreation and the therap beauty that's
what the little card is for we have the
good
stuff yeah and I and I think the idea
was that any franchisee essentially
would have the opportunity to
potentially sell those not just one or
seven they would have they would have to
be able to know what the car does of
otherwise qualified to be a
manage uh store and distribute
appropriately the higher concentration
and right now there three manufacturers
from these therapeutic grade is the term
I I've been using they would only remain
essenti we know who manufactures that
representative because we do so our next
meeting is
27th no it's going be the 23rd we have
one in the
23rd I actually left my uh physical
Calendar home it's Tuesday of next week
Tuesday next week
yeah it's up actually actually no it's
it's the 27th Monday the 27th Senator
ambus next week you do I thought you
were one of the few people in the
earlier question on like the chief
wanted a some type of nanogram for Miss
inference I thought you were one of the
few who didn't want that and I thought
the majority did maybe not a specific
number to theate but I I I would like to
have something in the law the problem is
I don't know what that something should
be and I'm trying to figure out when you
when we present if I was testifying for
a committee trying to convince them to
vote for it why would I pick two or five
and I know you're right don't smoke and
Dr well no no I'm so I'm undecided is my
point so we got to be stricter than
Colorado cuz they're they're uh they're
fatal Rex is going crazy I'm going to do
some my own research see I can I'm with
you
though um all right so
27th on the 27th what what will the
agenda be I mean if this is already
you've done the lining in and out so
what's the plan well we got to we got to
actually vote on a we got to put what we
hope is a final product together now
some of the final provision
remember this is going to go before
Commissions in the house I it's the
Committees in the house in the S so this
is not the bill it's Untouchable I
understand that it's not even no one's
even filed the
legislation um but we want to make a
recommendation on I think what a state
control model would be so the issue of
the nanograms the using uh smoking in
public th those are serious issues but
those are actually independent of the
state run model I think it's important
to have them all to do at once because
you don't want to have one without the
other but the finer details of whether
it's a $5 fine
misdemeanor the commission can make its
recommendation without coming to a
conclusion on that policy that could I
ask a follow-up question on on the the
report that we are mandated to write yes
in 611
um what is that going to look like are
we just going to be taking the um the
mark up that we've done and and will
that comprise the report or we going to
actually write a report every study
commission I've ever served on you write
a report majority and The Minority
Report be a majority and a Minority
Report but I would I Envision that if
there is a majority that or has any
proposed legislation and The Minority
Report can have the same too you know
like let's say you don't support this
but there's you may want to highlight
specific provisions of that attachment
that you not only I oppose it I really
really don't like this I double don't
like that you can you can reference it
the idea is to have something that's in
place but I I'm going to try to focus
really our debate on the state run model
and again like so the smoking in public
that is essentially whether it's the
violation as written $100 fine
misdemeanor doesn't impact the policy of
the state controlled model right so when
would you like The Minority Report uh
submitted to you I I think we we
submitted all at once am I correct it's
just it's just add on is a majority
report Minority
Report we just had a contentious one
with the worldwide re um um reporting on
taxation reporting and what we did there
was let the
minority uh author write their thing and
it was just attached as an appendix uh
the minutes were attached as an appendix
all of
the material that was put down was
listed as an appendix it wasn't included
in the body of the report the body of
the report was only five pages the the
rest of the 46 Pages were all right
bibliography and and The Minority Report
The Minority Report was much larger than
the majority
report I have a feeling it that'll be
again well all right so on the 27th are
we going to be able to we hopefully will
have a a draft by
then hopefully won't take us as long to
go through it the only thing I will say
is stuff about like smoking in public as
much as I'm adamantly up against that
this commission couldn't come to an
agreement on that that is I think we can
skip over those simply because that's
not what this commission is charged to
do I think it's important to go over it
but we focus on the state run model side
make sure that part is least
operational does that sound good
and if there is a updated draft you know
it kind of incorporates everything that
we've gone over um now keep in mind I'm
going to be relying on my notes and if
there's any problem with what's in there
and you don't agree with it just please
point it out but we'll
um we'll I'll try to distribute that as
early as possible when is our actual
report
due December
1st all right so if there's any changes
needs to be made to that
uh you know let's make let's be prepared
to have that proposed change that day
because we're not meeting again and and
that's that and what what's going to be
attached is you may want to have it in
writing your change that you want me to
it we have to incorp we have to vote on
that incorporate in it would have to now
be word for word it can't be something
like we kind of hypothetically wrote up
that
um at the outset of of this um study
commission uh we were asked to submit
God
rails which I have done on on behalf of
the prevention community and I know
others have as well what is the going to
be the process of integrating those God
rails into the mockup that we've done so
if we can if this commission agrees at
least the majority can come to a
consensus on a god rill I have no
problem putting it into it it's when we
when we're all over the place I think
the smoking in public one no one likes
what's in here no one liked any we
couldn't agree on any any of the um
proposals so I just left what's in there
is what we can't come to an agreement
it's what it is so I my point is the
charge of the commission is to put
together the state control model not
necessarily make a recommendation on
smoking or using in public I'm with you
on the public use I think it's you
intentionally violate the law you go out
of your way to do it people say you
don't have enough money to pay the fine
guess what they but they just went to
the store inv I don't know but that's
what that's the argument but guess what
we can't get a consensus so what to put
in here I don't know the advisement to
for the public to submit guard rails
will be completely disregarded then
that's what I'm hearing no that's that's
not what I said that's what I heard no
well that's not what I said what I'm
saying is if the commission can come to
a consensus on a guard room I have no
problem incorporating that into the
recommended legislation it's when we can
can't come to a consensus that if we
can't come to a consensus that's a
provision that perhaps should be in The
Minority Report but some of the guards I
agree with you on but if the commission
as a whole we can't come to a cons a
consensus on in all fairness it's been
months while since the whole commission
was
here that's why the the the voting will
be done on the last day we kind of just
got a consensus while we went going
through it fast but
I mean when you have a forum here and
it's unanimous I assume that that's
enough right even if people aren't
here um thank you chairman will we be
getting the report ahead of the 27th or
will we have time to review
it and before we're able to vote on it I
guess the question is
we well the report should be available
how long you think it would take to put
the report
together
so someone everyone can sign sign off on
23r are we meeting on the 23rd is that
you already had your friends giving so
you don't need thanks thank you senator
for attending you're welcome all right
um report wise I don't know I don't know
if that's to be able to be ready but I
think in order to put something together
I don't think it can be done by the 27th
but maybe we got to be prepared to be
here till 3 o'
again if that's all right with everyone
I just want to uh I'm going to be out of
state on the 27th so um former
representative suola will be here
sitting in my in my seat I have I have a
good uh idea which which direction
you're go yes
so I don't support proxy voting but if I
ever was I I wouldn't I would I would
already
know so all right any questions before
we you sign off the
reports un legislation can sign off by
email see all right everyone hear that
you can sign off by
email so the report but uh for the
Minority Report early you get in the
better and hopefully next
week any other questions by
anyone everyone good all
hold
thanks for the opportunity my name is
Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program I just
wanted to follow up on one point with
regard to the direction that uh was
discussed with uh regard to moving part
of the therapeutic cannabis program that
is the regulation of the atc's from thhs
to The Liquor Commission um I would ask
the commission to consider if they do do
that that the at CES that the
therapeutic cannabis program is funded
by ATC licensing fees so if that were to
move from HHS to Liquor Commission we
would lose a source of our funding and
so what that means is that we would need
a separate source of funding to fund our
program but is isn't the program now
moved under
liquor As I understood the conversation
the regulatory Authority uh for the ATC
licensing would be moved D but the
registry card um aspect of the program
the the patient registry would remain
with DHHS so we would still need funding
for uh the registry um program if you
will if we were if the ATC funding uh
part of the program was to move to
liquor so we need we would need an
appropriation um to uh continue to fund
the uh the patient registry if we lost
atcs
that see no thank you Mr thank
you any other questions
comments All right we are we adjourn for
today and I'll see you on 27 have have a
everyone